it's been a crazy week we have this
story out of Maryland and Portland where
pregnancy centers their their centers
for helping women who are pregnant and
are you know having uh doubts or having
issues or need support because they're
pro-life they've been ransacked by
pro-abortion activists and uh man the
violence and the uh just the the anger
it just keeps getting it keeps getting
worse I feel like people are becoming
more absolute in their positions and
unwilling to compromise I think most
people probably can see that as well
so we'll definitely talk about that
another element of the story is that
these activists
um a different group of activists or a
similar activist group published the
addresses of several Supreme Court
Justices because they're upset about the
leaked draft on Roe v Wade Jen sackey
essentially said Joe Biden doesn't care
that they don't care that it's happening
and also uh Joe Biden has uh no position
on abortionistry abortion restrictions
abortion restrictions so you've got now
I think Tim Ryan at Ohio said abortion
no restrictions none of our business and
that's where it is everything's becoming
more and more extreme now my view of it
is the right seems to be exactly where
they've been they've always wanted to
ban abortion the left now wants to
remove restrictions which is more to the
left of or more stream than they've ever
been so we'll talk about that too and
then in that in in line with that and
the other big news from the past week or
so Elon Musk Tesla has announced they
will cover the costs of women to travel
out of state to get abortions which
somehow involves Elon Musk again so
we're going to talk about censorship
Elon Musk uh there's a story where
apparently they're claiming Trump told
Elon Musk to buy Twitter he's denying it
so we're going to talk about this
censorship Marjorie Taylor green of
course won her court case she is
eligible to run for reelection but I
think the big conversation tonight
tonight is going to be hyper
polarization
ways to deal with it ways to connect
with people and joining us to discuss
this and probably one of the foremost
experts is Daryl Davis
good afternoon how are you I am
fantastic do you want to introduce
yourself I think you just did my name is
Daryl Davis I'm a 64 year old musician
author and lecturer and race
reconciliator right on you are I guess
you're you're the big story around you
aside from the fact that you're a famous
jazz musician is that you actually
de-radicalize clan members well I
Inspire them to do to de-radicalize
themselves I have been the impetus you
know a lot of the media says you know
black you know black blues musician or
black rock and roll musician uh converts
X number of klansmen no I never
converted anybody I have been the
impetus for over 200 to convert
themselves yeah absolutely cool well
this is going to be fascinating because
we talk about polarization a lot and we
actually did an event with you which is
really interesting and it's going to be
fun to talk about and kind of understand
what happened there but also we have
Bill ottman of Mines who can also talk
about you guys are working together on
censorship and how censorship is making
things worse absolutely thanks for
having me yeah I'm Bill I'm uh founder
of mindsminds.com check it out Daryl and
I just recently uh published a paper
together with multiple phds and a bunch
of researchers called the censorship
effect talking about the blowback of
censorship how to facilitate dialogue
and you know that's that's what we need
more of right on yeah man I'm down to
talk about censorship because I do
believe a little bit of censorship is
necessary otherwise you have a wild zoo
of people eating each other so you've
got to kind of you got to create a
little bit of uh adjust just sensorial
atmosphere in my opinion let's talk
about that later well just to add to
that point real quick some content is
illegal of course child abuse it's got
to be censored and that means someone
goes in has to remove it right dude I
just want to point out that you rocked
with Chuck Berry I didn't know for 37
you said 36 32 years but did you use my
keys with Chuck I mean he's created with
like inventing rock and roll he did
invent Rock so you kind of invented rock
and roll
no no I I came long after Johnny Johnson
was his original piano player I was born
in 1958 so right at the you know peak of
of rock and roll that is hot thanks for
coming brother all right you guys want
to get started yeah I am technically
here as well I just wanted to say too we
were late getting up to the studio today
because all of us who are supposed to do
the sound check were so enthralled by
what Daryl was telling us so I'm really
looking forward to this evening's
conversation I know the chat likes to
laugh at me for being excited about my
guests but I'm excited about this
conversation for sure it's gonna be
great before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member if you would
like to help support our work not only
are you helping us with our keeping our
journalists employed and we just brought
on another really amazing talented
personality to contribute to uh uh our
columns I suppose now that she has
articles up it's uh Josie the red-headed
libertarian on Twitter is going to be
writing uh articles and commentary for
us she's absolutely fantastic so I'm
thrilled that she was able to to come
and work with us and it's thanks to you
guys as members that make all that
possible so we'll do more as a member as
a member you'll get access to exclusive
segments from timcast IRL Monday through
Thursday at 8 pm we had a really
fascinating members only episode last
night where I got really mad about our
own website because I take this stuff
seriously I fact check or fact checked
our own site called it out and uh
because transparency is important as
well when we make mistakes I will I will
freak out out and call it out because uh
I think I owe you guys if you're members
we got to make sure we are better than
everybody else when it comes to getting
the facts straight so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's get started with this first story
I'm gonna start here actually and not
necessarily jump in with the violent
photos but this is part of the same
story White House refuses to condemn
activist group who posted home addresses
of Supreme Court Justices
we have another story out of Maryland
and Portland and there are these
pregnancy centers where activists went
and smashed up the windows and damaged
them ransacked them these are places
where they try and talk to women who are
pregnant they're called crisis pregnancy
centers
well activists who are associated with
the pro-abortion side of things
I guess just hate them and so they went
and vandalized and tagged them up I
think seeing stuff like this reached the
highest levels like the White House
where we learned that Supreme Court
Justices had their addresses posted
we've already seen people lose their
lives it shows that we're reaching this
very extreme level of hyperpolarization
so dare I don't know if you've been
following any of the current news about
the Roe v Wade stuff I mean things have
been kind of crazy over the past couple
of years or you know Bill if you've been
following the stuff but I I think we get
started with this the the modern uh
hyperpolarization and I'm curious what
your thoughts are with you know far left
as they were called or far right people
fighting in the streets or how about
just this right here you know
pro-abortion groups smashing up Windows
and vandalizing buildings
well you know that's been going on for
quite some time
um about probably 30 years ago there was
an anti-abortion person who was going up
and down the East Coast uh bombing
abortion clinics
and uh he got arrested I think down in
Florida another one uh murdered an
abortion doctor in Florida Dr Gunn
uh the the guy who um who bombed the
clinics lived lived right in Maryland
and I remember I was in bed one night at
my girlfriend's house and there was
thunder and lightning and she lived
right up against the woods
and we thought a uh a tree had been hit
by lightning
because the whole ground rock the things
fell off the walls everything four
o'clock in the morning and we jumped up
out of bed and then um you know still
thunder and lightning and raining
outside so at 7 30 that morning things
had died down we came outside all the
neighbors were out we're all looking in
the woods for this uh fallen tree and
um this is on a Sunday morning about 4
a.m it wasn't discovered until Monday in
Annapolis Maryland that uh that guy had
bombed the abortion clinic on the other
side of the woods wow how far away from
your house was it uh from her house it
was
um
gosh less than a quarter mile
it's wild yeah it feels like there are
political issues that are kind of
impossible in a sense like when we talk
with people who are pro-life because we
have you know Sheamus on the show
periodically and we have a lot of
conservatives and they're staunchly
pro-life their view of this is
for one most reasonable people most most
people and particularly like all
reasonable people think bombing an
abortion clinic is wrong and killing
people is wrong but you have you have
moral questions that arise if the
pro-life side genuinely believes that
babies are being murdered then they're
trying to stop murder
now how do you how do you how do you
solve for a problem like that if you
can't convince someone that it's wrong
to bomb a clinic you know what I mean
like if they if they believe in their
heart of hearts that they're saving
babies I don't I don't know if you can
convince them not to commit these these
acts
well I think you know that if they
they're convinced that you're murdering
babies and perhaps they're you know
they're not they're separating babies
from adults so in their minds I'm not
I'm not agreeing with them I'm saying
but in their minds they're murdering the
people who are murdering babies right so
therefore they're preventing the murder
of babies or I've just destroying that's
their justification right it's like this
is where things are getting interesting
because we talked about this yesterday
Louisiana has advanced a bill that will
make abortion homicide that will legally
list it as homicide so this is
I mean this is a political line that is
as hard as a line can be because once
that line is crossed that means you have
serious questions about whether or not
someone is Justified in using Force to
stop an abortion doctor from committing
an abortion
if the act of abortion is homicide then
there's a legal justification to prevent
that from happening that's if it's
codified
regardless of the law though there are
people who already believe that to be
the case I thought the conversation you
guys had down in Nashville sort of
theorizing about future technology that
could potentially enable a fetus to live
at a much earlier like that is a
fascinating philosophical conversation
that I think people just need to be
willing to have because but because that
is what it puts it into context makes it
less emotional well the fascinating
thing is uh we had this conversation
where
I I basically asked if there was a way
that from the moment of conception a
baby could be taken from the womb and
put into an artificial womb a machine
that would allow us to allow it to live
should we then ban abortion uh to the
extent that the baby is killed and only
allow procedures to terminate a
pregnancy if the pregnancy if the baby
is allowed to survive the the issue with
that I suppose is
everyone on the right basically says
like oh okay that's an interesting
question maybe separating from the
mother might be bad but I've asked a
handful of people on the left and they
say meh who cares no I don't know why
not whatever so not to get into a
technological discussion my question I
guess is I'm trying to get what I'm
trying to get into is
are there issues we can't mend are there
are there are there you know just ideas
that we're never going to be able to to
rectify amongst I believe I believe so I
mean you know we can come close but
there are always going to be issues that
that will crop up and then you know you
have uh what you just proposed there as
a possible viable solution but when you
have things that are that extreme on the
right that extreme on the left
you know you're not going to change
those people necessarily but what you
can do is uplift the middle when you
have that extreme polarization then what
you want to do is strengthen the middle
pull the middle up and in doing so you
will pull some of those uh people on the
left and some of the people on the right
into the middle as you do that sort of
like a Vortex yeah
yeah I think the have you heard the the
idea that
socialism is able to exist within
libertarianism but libertarianism was
not able to exist within socialism so I
think that that's a pretty powerful idea
I mean I don't necessarily know one way
or the other if it's true but it seems
like
it seems like a true fact what do you
guys think about that idea in a fully
libertarian system you have the right to
create a socialized system with no
problems in a fully socialized system
you've got a lot of checks and balances
you'd have to get through to create a
system where you're like I don't want to
be a part of that unfortunately you have
to because you're already part of it
that's the idea of social absolutely so
one of the issues now in the whole Roe v
Wade debate I tweeted about this earlier
we had Tim Ryan and we had Obama I'm
sorry not Obama we had Jen saki talking
about Biden I don't know why I said
Obama we had genseki talking about Biden
refusing to uh condemn late late term
abortions she was asked I think it was
by Ducey over at Fox News whether Biden
was in favor of restrictions on
abortions and she just you know he hot
around the answer and was like it's
between a woman a woman a doctor woman
or doctor Tim Ryan's the same thing so
for me I've always been kind of in the
center left position it used to be the
left liberal position in this country of
like in the first trimester maybe into
the second second and third trimester
abortion are kind of just not okay and
it's it's supposed to be safe legal and
rare but now you have one side saying
unrestricted up to nine months the woman
isn't about to go into labor the baby
can be aborted and then you have the
right saying ban outright in every
circumstance so how do you find that
middle I mean how do you how do you most
people are now finding them themselves
like there's no middle there's there's
very few people left
I think well I think part of it you know
depends upon the circumstances as to why
a particular woman wants an abortion I'm
not saying I I don't believe that all
abortion should be uh illegal I don't
believe that all abortions should be
should happen either but I think it
depends upon the circumstances uh if a
woman has been raped by a stranger if a
woman has been raped by her father or as
a young girl something like that uh you
know these are mitigating circumstances
it's already bad enough uh a rape is bad
enough that that woman is going to
remember that the rest of her life is my
traumatizer it's my traumatizer even
more if it's somebody within her own
family her father okay and if uh if that
child is produced
she's going to be confronted with that
child every day as a reminder is that
something that we want you know that
might be a decision for her to make and
not for us to make I suppose the issue
is you know we've we've we've talked to
a great a great deal this past week
about all the abortion but I think one
way to kind of validate the conversation
is what do you do when
when you have two competing political
factions that have just moved away from
each other well that's what Roe v Wade
is sort of bringing up in the cultural
conversation is like
should local areas make that decision
I'm not you know it's almost like that's
the solution then to repeal Roe v Wade
I'm or I'm overturned it yeah it's just
crazy how how controversial it is and
how emotional it is but we have to have
the conversation I I here's what I think
I think that we mentioned this briefly
the other day if you look at the history
of the United States and personhood that
we have a tendency to move towards
granting more personhood rights than
rescinding them that in almost every
circumstance we are continually
expanding who gets access to what we
deem to be civil rights it wasn't always
the case in the United States with
racism that uh people weren't granted
full civil rights with women not being
able to vote I actually think that based
on the trends of this country we're
going to move towards completely Banning
abortion outright that will come to a
point where people agree that they're
going to say we deem a an unborn baby to
be a human life guaranteed
constitutional protection what was it
like before Roe v Wade Daryl do you
remember much about it
yes but vaguely
was it like a big problem was abortion a
Hot Topic there wasn't so yeah it was
always a Hot Topic and and women were
you know giving abortions in secret uh
doing it themselves with a coat hanger
or having somebody else do it with a
coat hanger I remember friends of mine
even did that you know
um and then there were those who were
who were very uh vocal about it you know
they would come out and and say yeah I
had an abortion what about it you know
things like that but it was always very
controversial
and you know they they uh they were
there were a ton of abortion clinics
where you could go and get it done uh
legally and they were always you know
not almost say always but a number of
times there would be protests out in
front of the clinics it was particularly
more violent back then wasn't it
in some cases yeah like I mentioned the
guy I forgot to know what his name was
was Michael something who went up and
down the East Coast uh bombing the
abortion clinics
um yeah you know that that part was
violent and killing doctors who uh who
performed abortions as in Dr Gunn but
but not everything was uh was violent
you know there were a lot of loud vocal
protests in front of some of these
clinics let me let me ask you about your
view of how things have been going today
I mean there's been a lot in the past
several years with the Riots of the
country uh over George Floyd I'm curious
as to your perspective you're older than
us and so you certainly have seen way
more does it feel worse today in terms
of the political divide than it has in
the past
I wouldn't say that it really feels
worse you know there's always been a
divide but people today are more
outspoken
and less uh hidden about their views
there seems to be a more um emboldening
if you will today like you know you see
people who used to wear
um hoods and masks uh come out there
with their uh burning crosses and now
they come out in their regular clothes
and express the same views so they don't
feel like you know they have to hide so
much anymore because their jobs are
being threatened or whatever when did
you so let's like we can just get
started with your story for people who
aren't familiar do you want so just in
in terms of the context I'd love I want
to talk about modern politics and all
the stuff and where we are now but I
think your history might lend some
understanding a lot of people how did
you you're famous for being the how did
you describe it the um you inspired
people to
um de-radicalize the Clans members okay
so so to give you a little bit of
background on myself as I said I was I'm
64 years old but I grew up as the child
of parents in the U.S foreign service so
I grew up as an American embassy
I I was born in 58. I began traveling
around the world at the age of six of uh
of three in 1961.
and uh how it works is you you get
assigned to a country for two years you
come back here to the states you're here
for a few months maybe a year and then
you're assigned to another country
abroad so my first exposure to school
was overseas I I did Kindergarten first
grade third grade fifth grade seventh
grade and all the schools I went to
overseas this is back in the 1960s
my classmates were from Nigeria Japan
Russia Czechoslovakia Germany France
Italy Sweden anybody who had an embassy
in those particular countries all of
their kids went to the same school so
that became my Baseline as to what
school was supposed to be about I had
all these colors
you guys here are too young to remember
black and white TV but you know about it
I remember black and white TV and I
remember when color TV came in it was
like wow it's like a whole new dimension
right you know you never want to see
black and white TV again you saw
something In Living Color okay well
every time I would come back home
from overseas back to my own country the
United States it was like going from
color TV to black and white you know
because we did not have that amount of
diversity in this country in our schools
when I would come back I would either be
in all black schools or black and white
schools meaning they're still segregated
or the newly integrated just because uh
Brown versus the Board of Education
desegregated schools in 1954 it didn't
mean that integration took place
overnight it took years and years but
even in in many cases still it's not
exactly in fact the uh Prince Edward
County Virginia
shut down they refuse to integrate
schools the public schools they shut
down all public schools in Prince Edward
County Virginia not for five days not
for five weeks not for five months for
five years years okay imagine how much
education is lost in five years when you
go down there today people my age a lot
of them are basically functional
illiterates because they missed five
years of their education if you know if
they were in third grade you know they
didn't go back to school until they were
in eighth grade you know you know that
kind of thing
um so you know you're dealing with that
kind of thing so look look at kids today
who have to go to school over zoom over
the last two years because of the
pandemic some some kids did better than
others but a lot a lot of them did not
do so well over Zoom because they
weren't getting that personal one-on-one
education you know well as as an aside
too I want to do derail too much I think
we're gonna start saying something
similar because schools have started
adopting ideological Praxis in their
teachings so instead of telling a kid
you know two plus two equals four
they're saying two plus equals five
well
in what context are we talking so you
actually had a viral Trend where people
teachers were saying two plus two equals
five in one context it was that 2.4 plus
2.4 equals 4.8 which is rounded up to
five so if you round down 2.4 I don't
know what kind of Simplicity mess this
they were intending but it was it was
it's an issue of tribalism and this is
it's part of the polarization the idea
is that the people on the Right started
saying two plus two is four and sooner
or later the woke people are gonna say
it's not and then a point was being made
by you know left tribal people where
they're like two plus two could be five
here's how and then they say 2.2.4
rounds down to two but two point four
plus two point four is four point eight
which rounds to five therefore two plus
two is five and then most people who are
reasonable are just like 2.4 plus 2.4 is
4.8 end of story if you want to make
some weird equation that omits
information for the sake of making your
strange argument I guess yes but they're
teaching kids this you also have a lot
of the critical race Theory ideology
stuff in schools where the kids are
getting more of this kind of social
emotional learning as opposed to
actually learning stuff okay so let's
let's define two terms that you use just
just so that everybody's on the same
page not just us here but but everybody
out here listening to us so let's let's
define the term woke your definition of
term woke and your definition of the
term critical race Theory woke is
typically a reference to like a a left
tribal identifier so it has a reference
to critical race Theory critical theory
critical gender Theory encompasses these
different schools of thought
we gotta we got to Define all these
things critical race theory is
um basically the in the oh man it's
getting it gets tough to actually is
that a stink bug critical race theory is
critical theory in a racial context
critical theory is the the political
theory of the oppressed versus the
oppressors with Karl Marx back in the
day crit his critical theory was that
the wealthy oppress the poor the poor
the proletariat is oppressed the
bourgeoisie oppresses Kimberly Crenshaw
wrote a book called critical race Theory
which says this doesn't take into
context the race the racial component of
the United States therefore critical
race theory is white people are dominant
and they oppress all people of color so
critical race theory has several
different subsequent schools of thought
like intersectionality that a black
woman experiences different
discrimination than a black man because
there's also sexism plus racism but the
sexism plus racism is a different
category than the sexism that a white
woman would experience so this is
another school of thought Within the
realm of critical race Theory critical
race Praxis is the implementation of
these ideas into standardized learning
an example would be if I were to give
you a math problem I would say a train
leaves Pittsburgh traveling at 100 miles
an hour a train leaves Cincinnati
traveling at 75 miles an hour they're
300 miles apart how long blah blah blah
critical race Praxis gives math problems
to kids like in Florida Jerome was
stopped by the police 17 times in the
past month Harold was stopped three
times what percentage are black people
stopped by police more than white people
so what they're doing is it is a math
question but they're injecting an
ideology a Praxis of critical race
assuming that Jerome was black well they
do these things that are overtly racist
absolutely and but it'll show a little
black character and it'll show a little
white character and then they'll they'll
do this problem and so we've started
seeing the emergence of a lot of that
what I see from this is uh one viral
video that went around is a kid who
didn't understand pronouns because this
is an awokeness includes what is crit
what is called critical gender Theory
which is boys and girls don't exist
doctors guess gender and so there's a
video of a little boy asking uh he he's
doing a pronoun worksheet
and it says something like Juan gets on
the swing which pronoun would you use
Janet uses jump ropes which pronouns
would you use and he put they for all of
them and his mom goes why did you put
they for all of them and he says how am
I supposed to know if they're boys or
girls and she said didn't you notice
their names and he was like but you said
there's no boys or girls and names and
so now the kids don't understand basic
English grammar because of these of the
Praxis being injected in in our you know
in the current generation the current
Learning Systems so
not to derail too much from what you
were saying because now we're getting
particularly verbose uh when you talk
about these schools the first thing I
think of is at this point schools have
become so corrupt in many ways I think
regardless of whether we have them or
not people are going to become
functionally illiterate
basically when you mention functional
illiterates I thought of the kid who
didn't know how to use pronouns and
everything that comprises that problem
we're experiencing
assuming that that he doesn't know that
Janet is a female name or now it's uh
androgynous right where Janet could be a
male name or a female name like for
example my name is Daryl uh for the
longest time I thought Daryl was always
a male name until an actress came along
named Daryl Hannah that's right
well so uh so that defines Wellness was
there another another term no that was a
Welcome Center critical race Theory yeah
okay well there we go I think the
impossible thing about it is that
everything is Blended together and so
every issue becomes into with
intersectionality the like the reality
is that if you're talking about race
you're talking race and gender are
different conversations but yeah they're
the same conversation and so it makes it
it makes it really hard to to talk about
anything because so woke Blends all of
that together and it's just that's it's
hard to Define because it also means
different things to different people I
think I could Define wokeness as like
it's like a faux Awakening people feel
like they're having Awakening right now
and but it's it's an Awakening to like
what they're being told is is real so
they just believe what they're told
rather than a real like Central
Awakening of like having like a reality
shift or a you know what I mean it's not
like a like an internal struggling I
mean maybe it is for them they're
probably having a similar feeling to
someone that's actually had a spiritual
awakening on a hill meditating for 40
days but it's like a false Awakening and
people are making fun of it calling it
oh they're woke they're so awake now
have you ever heard the term red build
red build red pilled
no it's the inverse of woke but they
basically mean the same thing okay if
you are red pill it's a reference to the
Matrix you get the blue pill the red
pill the red pill wakes you up from the
illusion of reality woke means you've
awoken to what's really going on and so
they mean effectively the same thing a
great realization of the lies you've
been told based on my understanding and
I think a fair research red pilled is a
bit trolley and more tongue-in-cheek
woke is zealous and ideological but I
also think the woke stuff is
manipulative and wrong for the most part
so you know we often have people on here
and I talk well okay so so for example
uh when I was in high school
uh we were taught in the textbooks I've
still got my textbooks that uh that
Robert uh uh Perry uh Admiral Perry uh
discovered the um the North Pole
not true
you know Matthew Henson discovered the
North Pole Admiral Perry was a white guy
Matthew Henson was a black guy Matthew
Henson was Admiral Perry's best friend
and they went on the exploration
together okay Perry got sick
and told Henson to go on Henson went on
and discovered the North Pole all right
interesting when uh they got back
Perry told everybody it was handsome
they said no we can't give him the
credit and they gave the credit to
Admiral Perry all right Admiral Perry
was buried in Arlington Cemetery
Matthew Henson was buried in a pauper's
grave
in the 1980s when Ronald Reagan was uh
was in office as president uh there was
a a bill put forth Coretta Scott King
and some other people came to him and he
uh passed this bill now in the textbooks
it says Matthew Henson discovered the
North Pole now I knew that all along
because my parents told me even though
it wasn't in the textbook all right
um they exhumed Matthew Henson from the
pauper's grave grave and now he's buried
next to his best friend uh Admiral Perry
in Arlington Cemetery when I was in
school we did not learn that this
country had interment camps for Japanese
Americans
I didn't learn that until I was in
college and I was incredulous I'm like
what are you kidding me no way and I
asked my parents and they're like yeah
you know why wasn't it why wasn't it in
our textbooks because it was a it was a
dark blemish on our history it was a
shameful thing that we did in this
country so did I become woke when I was
in college but that's not weakness all
right so what is it what so uh an
example of wokeness is saying things
like all white people are racist
all white people are not racist but
that's wokeness is not a reference to
understanding how history works so I'll
give you an example when I was a little
kid uh I was told in school Christopher
Columbus discovered America which is
just not true they were already people
here but did you know that yes because I
had uh I had a mom who told me there
were already people here right and I I
tell the story all the time she said
actually Leif Erickson came to the to
the North American continent a thousand
years before Christopher Columbus but
honey there were already people there
weren't there and I was like yeah and
she goes did they teach you they were
already people there and I was like yes
and she goes didn't they discover this
continent and I was like yeah I was like
then why did they tell me that and she
said they think you're stupid but
they'll tell you the truth in college
and that was like a real
anti-authoritarian moment for me as a
kid so was that an Awakening or or awoke
so wokeness doesn't refer to learning
the truth wokeness is typical I mean
depending on who you're talking to if
you're talking to people who are trying
to avoid the overt ideologies of either
you know extremists whatever any
extremist faction wokeness is typically
a pejorative term to reference someone
who says you're white so you're racist
that's considered to be woke now some
people might use woke in a more relaxed
manner like perhaps towards the angle
you're describing it but uh based on
like this show and how we approach
things most people who watch would
probably say they're anti-woke but they
completely agree with what you've said
or would completely agree with the idea
that Native Americans already were here
right the proper way to describe it is
Christopher Columbus discovered uh the
Bahamas for Europeans as part of the
European culture he was the first to
kind of bring that information to them
but again Leif Erickson also of European
descent discovered it it didn't really
make the rounds in the European
continent and other people were already
here who had discovered the land
typically typically people do not use
woke as like a badge you know people
who's even more critical people don't no
they don't they don't and so so people
who are like pro-critical race Theory
wouldn't necessarily call themselves
that and I think look most people are
pro-uncensored history I think that is a
common thing that we need to get on this
no I I would have to disagree with you
well maybe I don't I'm I'm I don't have
a statistic in front of me but I think
we all here want well some uncensored
history so it gets complicated because
critical race Theory some people are
trying to say the critical race theory
is the truth of History that's some
people's perspective other people would
agree with teaching what you just said
was omitted right but that wouldn't that
that's not the same as critical race
Theory so take a look at this image this
is part of a book called not my idea in
which grade school children are shown
the whiteness contract with a white hand
reaching out and a devil tail and goat's
feet I think this is wrong to teach
children that white people are
inherently evil inherently oppressors or
inherently racist that all white people
are racist and this is what woke
typically means when we criticize it I
think uh we should tell people that some
people are good some people are bad and
race is not relevant to whether someone
will be a good or bad person you've got
to find out who they are within would
you agree I would agree 100 with that
well the problem is is what they're
teaching kids in school dude we can see
your pointy tail contract binding you to
whiteness you get stolen land stolen
riches special favors whiteness gets to
mess endlessly with the lives of your
friends neighbors loved ones and fellow
humans of color sign below for the
purpose of profit land riches and favors
may be revoked at any time for any
reason showing a white hand reaching out
with a whiteness contract and Devil's
tale I think is
particularly dangerous to be teaching
children okay but now so
that's called critical race Theory by
your definition correct yes okay but
there are also people who are calling
critical race Theory
teaching the transparent history okay
people people Banning books uh not not
talking about these are the books being
banned
those are not the only books being
banned right they're they're talking
about banning books on Rosa Parks
biography out of schools not talking
about slavery not talking about you know
oppression and things like that they're
calling that critical race Theory as
well but hold on uh-huh
the challenge with this is I'm not
familiar with a book on Rosa Parks being
banned and in the experience that we've
all had here and probably most of our
listeners
when uh recently Florida banned math
books the left came out woke people and
said see now they're banning math the
issue was they were Banning the math I
explained to you where the math problem
isn't a math question it says how many
people are racist blah blah blah so
Florida said we don't want ideological
Praxis in our math books we want math
problems so when we hear that they're
banning books it's a question of which
books why well what we did was we had
several experts on who brought the books
to us and showed us this is this is the
easiest and most notable example saying
whiteness is the devil do you remember
about four years ago the state of Texas
changed all the the school public school
books they removed the word slave and
slavery and changed it to immigrant
worker
that would be bad at the same time the
New York Times removed the word slave
from their game Wordle because it was
offensive so I would consider all of
that to be in the same line of
authoritarian censorship we don't want
okay so there was a big protest and I
think was MacMillan and press or
whatever they did all the Texas uh
school books had to recall all those
books and and re rewrite them and now
it's uh enslaved people as opposed to
Slaves so they there is an effort I
think they did this didn't they remove
master and slave from some coding
language yeah for on git right yeah so I
oppose exactly what you described and
what what no matter where it's coming
from typically what we're seeing today
I don't think woke people
well actually I take that back uh they
literally banned the word slave from get
they GitHub GitHub and the New York
Times They have this game called Wordle
where it's every day you try to guess a
five-letter word you literally can't
guess the word slave because it's
offensive
I think that's bad I don't think books
should be I don't I don't think I don't
think this book should be banned from
schools I think this book should be
banned from curriculum in which the
teacher says child learned the truth
whiteness is the devil I think a teacher
could say to a more age-appropriate
group take a look at this book and what
these people believe about this idea and
approach it but but there are people who
also consider critical race Theory
showing pictures of uh of the four black
people trying to integrate the
Woolworths food counter and having stuff
poured on their heads the girl walking
Ruby Bridges walking into the school
with the white people yelling behind her
and all that yeah but but they consider
that critical race Theory and they don't
want their kids seeing that but so so
the issue is
these things can exist within the
ideology of critical race theory in the
context of critical race theory is
rooted in Marxist uh the Marxist uh
philosophy of oppressed and oppressor I
do not agree with that I think that's
wrong and I think when you put a racial
tone on that it's extremely dangerous
because what they've started doing in at
Dearborn University and our Dearborn uh
Michigan they created a POC and non-poc
digital Cafe meaning white people only
people of color only in Seattle they
created diversity Equity inclusion
events for POC only non-poc only and
that's under critical race Theory and
they Justified exactly how you explained
it they show racism from the past we all
think is wrong and then say see
shouldn't black people have their own
private spaces separate from white
people and I say if people in a private
context you know within a certain reason
I guess it's fine if you have a private
club in public accommodations like
universities and and you and libraries I
don't think they should be allowed to
force genders segregation I'm sorry
racial segregation they're the ones who
actually want to get get rid of gender
segregation well just just a few years
ago uh what maybe maybe four years ago
five years ago maybe even less
um a high school in Mississippi the
principal had two separate proms a black
prom and a white prom and you were not
allowed to have any integrated couples
and was this a was this a critical race
theorist who had implemented it
they kind of overlap because it wouldn't
be surprising if there are cases in the
country where there's actual old school
segregation but you sort of have new
school segregation and old school
segregation coming together so Daryl
like what is your response to the kind
of the new take a look at this right uh
I'm willing to bet the story you heard
was actually about someone who was woke
creating black only spaces like this
story we have from Atlanta no it wasn't
a black person creating the segregated
no they're white liberals who do these
things there there are white Progressive
women who are overwhelmingly the woke
who are creating racially segregated
spaces it's against the law Atlanta
parent filed complaint over alleged
segregation of classrooms this wasn't a
white right-wing racist who created this
it was a progressive white woman who
created white only I'm sorry I'm sorry I
think this was actually a black
principle in the school they segregated
all the black students under the guise
of critical race Theory saying that
there's an idea that came from uh Derek
Bell are you familiar with Derek Bell
he believed that Plessy versus Ferguson
was correct that's separate uh but equal
was the right way to approach racial
issues I believe it was Derek Bell so uh
I don't have the book pulled him in
front of me one of the arguments that
I've heard um at least him be attached
to and I heard quite frequently with the
black lives matter protests was that
before desegregation the black community
had their own wealth their own
neighborhoods and they had their own
economy
segregation took a weaker economy in the
black community and forced it into the
white economy putting it underneath it
allowing white people to then oppress
black industry and black business that
is the justification they use for
bringing back segregation the actual
argument among the woke that Plessy V
Ferguson was right and I me I I come
from uh second generation mixed race
family who told me the stories of life
before loving V Virginia and the Civil
Rights Act and the things they went
through getting spit on I'm sure you
know better than you and I do because I
just I grew up after the fact and so
when I started hearing the things that
were coming out of the modern iteration
of the left and critical race Theory I
said those are bad racist things we
should oppose
okay so now let's let's understand
something okay so when you say that uh
you know they they say okay all white
people are oppressors all white people
are racist all black people are victims
and they'll always be victims no I I
don't agree with that you know that's
not the way it is okay but that's the
core definition of critical race Theory
no it's not the core definition I gotta
stop basically critical theory critical
theory was Marx's approach to
class-based oppression and he said the
rich oppressed the poor Kimberly
Crenshaw in her opening chapter
literally says white people oppress
black people it is critical race Theory
no I disagree with that I'd have to see
that because I've seen Kimberly Crenshaw
interviewed okay and and she has been uh
challenged with that by the other guy
what's his name kindy or somebody
ibrahamex candy yes okay well there's
two different schools they're both the
same school no two different schools no
no no no no no okay what you're saying
uh leans more towards what uh candy has
stated for my for my uh uh watching uh
Crenshaw be interviewed no that is not
the case Okay
um I don't have the computer here to
bring it up but uh but I would say
research that uh that that is not you
know there are several different
definitions of critical race Theory and
so you know there's no one universal
definition of it I think what happened
is that the Romans uh had a slave
accuracy that spread into Europe and
then into like feudalism so they had
still slaves as like their feudal people
the The Peasants and then they because
their skin happened to be white or light
then they had enslaved people from
around the North African coast and the
East so that their slaves happen to have
different color skins and now because of
that it's created a system where the the
generations that follow those slaves had
less education and less wealth and the
slave owners but it didn't wasn't
because the skin color it just happened
to be the Roman Empire happened to be
the dominating Empire I don't think well
you know the Roman Empire evolved Out of
Africa okay Italians come from Africa
the Moors the Moors exactly precisely
Kimberly and Southern Southern Italy
those Italians are dark yeah the
Sicilians particularly exactly precisely
and I think that the the racial
component's been misappropriated to this
class issue that we have of like the
descendants of slaves like fifth sixth
seventh generation slave children of
like you know the great great
grandfather was a slave didn't have any
education so there's no familial wealth
or there's less familial wealth my
great-great-grandfather was a slave okay
I'm a descendant of slaves wow okay now
we you know we were promised
um at the end of slavery what 40 acres
and a mule
find me one person who got that okay
Japanese Americans who were in interment
camps or their descendants have received
um reparations
Native Americans if you have one
sixteenth Native American blood you can
get a government money okay I got
Cherokee in me but I've never gone to
get any money from it okay
so we we've made the apologies the
Native Americans we've made the
apologies to uh Japanese Americans
this country has never never apologized
for slavery the person who came the
closest to apologizing but never
apologized was uh President Bill Clinton
what he said was slavery was wrong those
are his words now saying something is
wrong and saying we're sorry for doing
it are two different things how many
people uh die deliberating the Japanese
from the internment camps
I don't know the numbers I think it's
zero well they just opened the camps
after the war didn't they I don't know I
think this country overtly did wrong by
putting people in these camps and then
realized they did wrong but I think they
also they also did wrong by by by
putting people in shackles and selling
them on the courthouse steps as property
absolutely I suppose that the main
difference though I actually agree with
you um I think I I actually think there
should be some form of reparations but I
I don't know if it's ever been uh I
don't know if the politicians will ever
actually do anything meaningful in terms
of this and what's that called
lying no it's called racism that they
won't do anything meaningful but I mean
you have black uh political leaders who
also won't do anything you got black
people who who are worthless just like
you got white people who are worthless
nobody has a monopoly on racism or or
being worthless I don't think I don't
think that it's a prejudice against race
is the reason why they're not doing it I
think it's because they want to hold
that over as an issue to gain power in
politics Have you listened to Coleman's
Coleman's arguments on reparations
Coleman Hughes yeah I mean so it's a I
don't think
the fact that it hasn't happened yet
necessarily means racism it's it's more
so extremely complicated because where
do you draw the line what percentage of
black do you have to be like it's very
accomplished I just have to say it's not
complicated at all listen
what you know does racism exist yes or
no yeah I think that people are afraid
of what they're not familiar with
sometimes but but does racism exist well
there's no we're the same race we're the
human species like I I understand
there's only one race but you know what
I mean
does racism exist in this country are
there people of different colors who are
discriminated against okay uh this
country owned people as property okay we
were considered people like me were were
considered three-fifths of a human being
we were bought and sold on the
courthouse steps families ripped apart
just like when you got your first pet
you know somebody's cat or dog had a
litter and your parents took you in and
said pick out one and you took that
kitten or that puppy from its mother
that's what happened to human beings in
this country okay we would we were taken
from our our families we were raped in
front of our children in front of of
mothers husbands and things like that
you know about
um nine out of every 10 black people in
this country have some white blood in
them so
um you know some of it some of it
consensual some of it non-consensual let
me tell you this Thomas Jefferson you
all know he had a slave mistress right
yeah named Sally Hemmings but I bet you
didn't know this and if you doubt me
check it out
what was uh Thomas's uh wife's name was
it was it uh Martha or Mary I forgot now
I think it was Martha wasn't it Martha
Jones no uh Jefferson I remember uh
Washington's wife she's Martha for sure
okay
they're both Martha they're both Martha
okay like Bruce Wayne and Superman
they're moms Bruce Wayne and Superman
they're both their moms are Martha okay
Kent and uh Martha Wayne okay so
um
Sally Hemmings who was Thomas president
Thomas Jefferson's slave mistress
did you know that she was a half-sister
to Thomas Jefferson's wife Martha
Jefferson
uh-huh you need to check that out that's
not in your history book but you can
find it because Thomas Jefferson's
father-in-law Martha Martha's uh father
okay he had slaves too right and he had
an affair with a Sally Hemmings mother
which produced Sally hemings if you look
at a picture of of Martha Jefferson and
a picture of Sally Hemmings they looked
very similar one darker one lighter how
much is uh one human life worth it's
worth a lot you can't put a you can't
put a value on it 828 000 casualties
from the Union soldiers fighting to end
slavery 828 000 people died endless
amounts of wealth destroyed Holmes
ransacked burned completely destroyed
the country almost collapsed trying to
end this so while I still believe that
there's an issue of operations in terms
of we cannot have you know people you
know I've mentioned systemic racism on
the show and people don't agree but I
think it's because people misunderstand
what what the idea actually is behind it
so uh we'll get to that in a second I
think there needs to be uh you know I I
lean liberal on all these positions
there needs to be some way to strengthen
the uh the weakest link in this country
those who are historically a pop first
or generationally impoverished I think
after we did away with a lot of the laws
that were bad I think after we had
Constitutional Amendments and then
ultimately new laws that codified you
cannot do these things we now need
class-based Solutions which should
desperate fortunately help those who are
disproportionately affected okay so in
the 1940s and 1950s
a lot of black people in this country
moved to France
now people over in France are a lot
whiter
than white people in this country
all right the French people treated
these black people as equals
that's why we moved there Eartha Kitt
was one of them who played like uh
Catwoman on Batman she's the one who had
the cat growl right
um
uh
uh James Earl not James or Jones um Paul
Robeson Memphis slim uh Josephine Baker
a lot of these people moved to France
because they were being treated as
equals all right so uh you know when
people say all white people are are
oppressors no that's not true okay that
that that's because people have been
exposed to only a a small group of white
people and those are the people here in
this country people in France did not
oppress black people all right they
didn't own slaves this country owned
slaves look okay look think you guys are
too young to remember
um
there there is only one holiday in this
country one holiday in this country uh
that um that is named after a uh a uh an
American man
one holiday in this country that's named
after an American man
and guess what that man is black
and people had a fit over that it took
decades to get Martin Luther King Day
people did not want to put it up there
because he's a black man there used to
be two white guys who had a holiday each
to himself
one we used to have George Washington
day and we had Abraham Lincoln day and
then it was decided that we had too many
holidays so they combined Washington day
and Lincoln Day into one day called
President's Day all right but I remember
when I went to school we got off we're
watching the day and we got off for
Lincoln day all right now but we had to
fight fight fight to get Martin Luther
King day yet we celebrate we celebrate
there is another guy who has a holiday
all to himself all right he's not an
American he didn't discover a damn thing
he was a murderer a Pillager and a
rapist and his name Christopher Columbus
okay Martin Luther King never raped
anybody never pillaged any place and
never and and
he he gave his life bringing people
together but yet we had no problem
celebrating Christopher Columbus who
didn't discover America as Tim said how
do you discover something people are
already here when you arrived yeah his
brothers were the real psychos too uh uh
Columbus let his brothers ransacked I
think it was were they in Haiti is that
where they set up shop it was in the
Bahamas somewhere and he just let his
two brothers like drag women down the
street by their hair as they would beat
him and rape them and stuff it was hey I
want to confirm a couple things you
mentioned earlier from Newsweek uh
there's an article from this is like uh
September 21 Martin Luther King Jr and
Rosa Parks books among those banned in
Pennsylvania School District I didn't
read into this article and I don't know
why they were banned but that's an
article from Newsweek I'll tell you
here's the here's the journey very quick
the other thing is Sally Hemmings is
apparently the half-sister of
Jefferson's wife Martha Wales Jefferson
that's from monticello.org one of the
challenges with uh any any cursory story
about banning books is that we recently
had a book banned in a bunch of schools
called genderqueer The Washington Post
in the New York Times wrote that it's
just a story about growing up queer and
a story that kids need but the book
actually also displays graphic images of
sex between what is probably minors and
Amazon rates it as being 18 up when you
hear the story just in passing or on the
surface if you actually read the New
York Times in the Washington Post they
won't tell you why the book was actually
banned they'll simply say anti-trans or
anti-queer bigots banned the book
because they're banning books you then
actually open the book and say whoa they
wanted middle schoolers to see [ __ ]
yeah I don't know about that but that's
actually in the book I can't show you
the book on YouTube because we get
banned if we showed it so Tim can you
confirm that there's kind of a split
within critical race Theory between
these two different camps that Daryl's
talking about well I call it a modern
Bailey right so when you actually uh in
that what is it the I always confuse the
two one of them are you from the
mountain Bailey argument no they'll say
something like we're just trying to
teach the the true history of racism in
America
and then you go oh okay well then what
is this or I'm sorry that the way it
works is they'll say something like all
white people are racist all white people
are oppressors because whiteness is
property Kimberly cruncher actually said
that it's in her original book whiteness
has property grants people specific
access to things other people can't
therefore white people oppress all other
people of color you then say hey whoa
wait a minute you can't call all people
racist you can't show a picture of a
devil who's white with a whiteness
contract and then they go we're just
trying to explain the true history of
this country
uh it's a modern Bailey argument you
start with this very aggressive approach
and then when someone actually
investigates and call you out you
Retreat saying no no no no it's just
about the true history of this country
so for someone like me
the true history of this country is this
country was built on racism okay it was
it was be I mean
the world itself is still just racist
but the United States no no no no no no
no no no no no the world itself is not
racist this country is racist there is
discrimination in the world for example
in Northern Ireland okay like here in
our country if you're a Catholic and I'm
Protestant there's no big deal no who
cares in Northern Ireland
it's conflict oh yeah that's not racism
okay that's symbolism okay and Noah's
religion okay and um it's tribalism so
uh if you so having I'm not trying to be
an expert on the Irish Republicans and
the Protestants the Catholics and they
weren't George or anything but at least
having been there and and covered this
both sides of this it's not about
Protestant or Catholic that maybe that
that may be what it's described as but
you notice really weird things one
side's pro-palestine one side's
pro-israel one side believes in
socialism one side believes in
capitalism one side is pro militaristic
imperialism one side is
anti-intervention what happens is two
different factions hate each other and
they adopt whatever the other side
opposes and so tribalism emerges where
what we're experiencing right here right
now with with uh Republicans and
Democrats right that's that's why it's
that tribalism yes absolutely that's why
you're definition okay so when they say
Candace Owens is a white supremacist
something is wrong right they said I was
a white supremacist something's wrong I
don't always agree with Candace Owens
though right so the issue is for me I
don't think race uh is the principal
component of the defied right now I'm
not saying racism doesn't exist I'm
saying in a separate issue we have a
problem of tribalism in this country and
I think just not to derail you because I
was mentioning that's right when you
mentioned Northern Ireland as being
religious it's it's Tribal it's it
started as a religious conflict that
became more tribalized over time that's
the same with politics let's go from
from Northern Ireland to Lebanon see
there is Christians and Muslims and
Israel is Jews and Palestinians okay so
these are are religious discriminations
you wouldn't call it racism in this
country it's racism okay you know people
people were bought and sold people were
owned this country was built on a
two-tier Society white supremacy at the
top and slavery at the bottom that's
what built this country and as we
progressed over the decades we
progressed like this
maybe like this is it but never like
this is it fair to say that Native
Americans were on the bottom
yeah absolutely they were absolutely
they were on the bottom absolutely you
know not not I'm not sure I'm not I
don't know
Etc I don't know if we should make it
you know and to this day we still
discriminate against Native Americans
you know there are a lot of phrases you
know that you don't even realize that
are that are uh uh pejorative or
derogatory like you know you say you
know man that guy went off the
reservation
yeah where do you think that comes from
right or it's none of your cotton
picking business what do you think that
comes well that one we all know okay it
was like Foghorn Leghorn man or he comes
from the uh or he comes from the wrong
side of the tracks so Daryl your
president how do you deal with this
who's my president
no I'm saying theoretically if you were
president If I Was President if you were
president how are you handling this
I'm having more talk more discussion I'm
the same way I'm handling it right now I
bring opposing forces together what
about specifically in terms of
reparations what would you like to see
what I would like to see a is an apology
okay and B uh reparations in terms
perhaps of of Education tuitions not
necessarily be handing out people money
necessarily but provide people the means
to get a great education all right
because that way you can you can uplift
you can help uplift yourself what do you
think let's go back to the abortion
thing what do you think about the
history of Planned Parenthood are you
familiar with it the history of it no
I'm not Margaret Sanger was I know the
name but I'm not familiar with all the
eugenicist and one of her uh we can't
say the name of the project she created
because it uses an iteration of the
n-word which would get us in trouble on
YouTube but her idea was to go around to
the black community and start
um propagating birth control practices
to stop black people from having kids
let me tell you something my mother was
a victim of that okay there was a big
Scandal back in the 50s where doctors
were systematically giving women
hysterectomies and in order to to cut
down the black population that's right
and my mother was a victim of that and
you don't find that out until you know
20 40 years later just like the Tuskegee
experiment just like agent orange you
know the government doing all these
kinds of things and you don't find out
about it until much later
yeah or like uh Pfizer data dumps and
stuff like that they wanted to wait 75
years to give that information out but I
digress I'm into repairing the system
too reparation whatever you want to call
repairing it and I agree I don't think
throwing money at people is the way to
repair right the communication I mean
obviously communication is real do you
think school choice is legit or you
follow that at all school choice yeah
it's instead of like people sending
their kids to a public school every year
that costs a certain amount of money
instead you get a voucher for that
amount of money that you can spend at
any school of your choice or
homeschooling if you set up a
homeschooling curriculum
uh does that appeal to you at all
uh I'd have to I'd have to look at that
also it was very vague and I don't know
if I described it exactly right but it's
the idea that instead of being
um having to adhere to a public school
system or private that you would get to
choose what you where you send your kid
and you'll you'll have credits along
with that because I think education and
communication is the key to moving
forward absolutely I do 100 I'm I'm 100
pro education and you know it would have
to be schools that uh you know that are
top-notch you know you would have the
right to go to those schools I mean
there was a time where I couldn't go to
Harvard where I couldn't go to Princeton
because because of the color of my skin
that's why we have what we call hbcus
right historically black colleges and
universities that's why the United Negro
College Fund was founded and things like
that
um so and by the way I went to an HBCU I
went to Howard University uh which was
founded by General George Howard who was
a white guy
is that gonna do it
so uh I'm trying to pull up the specific
story
Google's not too uh let me let me see if
we can do this I I did have another
thing pulled up I want to ask you about
sure I I hope that YouTube can start to
understand context of language well I
mean we'll see if they can if the
algorithm detects the word that Daryl
just said and demonetizes the video that
is just so unacceptable no it's okay
it's okay you use use the n-word which
so you look and n word oh let me let me
let me ask you uh
we have a story from independent Harvard
University will hold first ever black
only graduation ceremony on this is from
May 2017. do you agree with institutions
creating racially segregated no so I I
agree with that and this is this is not
coming from the right this is coming
from
like I said nobody has a monopoly on
stupidity let me I want to ask you about
the abortion thing because it's big in
the news and this is a really
fascinating one because one of the
things we hear from a lot of people on
the pro-life side is that the foundation
of Planned Parenthood was Eugenics
eugenicists who wanted to depopulate the
black you know population community in
this country I just pulled up the uh
1990 to 2006 it's a census government
um abortion demographic and the
interesting thing is that in 2006 for
every 1 000 women there were 14
abortions but for every one thousand
black women there were 50 abortions so I
look at this and I think this is that
tribalism or is that racism I think it's
racism both probably absolutely I think
racist I think when you look at the
locations of Planned Parenthood
facilities they tend to be in Black and
Latino areas not lower income areas just
like um when you look at all the
advertisements and billboards
um for cigarette smoking and and alcohol
usually in impoverished black areas yep
so I I'm curious as to what you you know
what your thoughts on this would be you
know why is it that in 2006 for for
every one thousand uh black women
there's 50 abortions but every one for
for every one thousand white women
there's 14 abortions how do you think
something like that happens
racism
racism sure but like is it are there
racists who are advocating for you know
are these pro-choice racists who are
trying to trick black people or how is
it racist
they're trying to cut okay let me tell
you what's happening here
when when you were a kid even though you
were a lot younger than I am and when I
was a kid
when you even when your parents were
kids
and your grandparents were kids
the black population in this country was
12 percent
Native Americans one percent
Hispanic people around 2 percent
uh Asian people around three percent
whites 86 87 percent all right
the U.S census is taken every decade
every 10 years you can Google
uscensus.gov and see the trends all
right
today
black people remain just over 12 percent
like 12.9 13 all right Native Americans
remain at one percent
um Asians have pretty much doubled
they're like at 5.9 almost 6 percent
Latino Hispanic people have more than
quadrupled 17 something percent
if you if you take just
black people 12 percent Hispanic people
17 that right there is 29 non-white
that's almost a third right this is
happening all right uh today the the
last census was was last year I'm sorry
two years ago 2020. all right white
people in this country right now are 59
all right in the year 2042 which is two
uh decades from now
this will happen for the first time in
our country this country will be 50
white 50 non-white all right for the
first time between 2045 and 2050 it's
going to flip and whites will become the
minority in this country whites are
already the minority globally but in
this country they are the majority uh
you guys may may know the term white
flight yep okay white flight barely
exists in our country anymore because
America the the color of America's
landscape has changed so much that
anywhere you go there's already somebody
there who doesn't look like you and so
People Are People there's a large swath
of the America of the white American
population that doesn't care about this
happening hey it's Evolution I don't
care no big deal I don't have a problem
with that but there's also a large swath
that does care about that they feel
they're getting squished out you know
you know we built this country we wrote
the Constitution you know and now you
know our our identity is being you know
squashed out both race mixing and people
moving us out and so forth and so on so
they they are fearing this happening
and this is a problem for them and this
is why you know we're seeing a lot of
these things you know that you're
talking about voting rights changing
um and people you know uh I'm sorry good
just what voting rights in particular
where they're trying to rewrite the
Voting Rights bill and what's going to
be next the Civil Rights bill right well
I just asked because they're doing it
everywhere and it's the left and the
right
so I'm not sure the context right so in
in a bunch of the blue areas they've
they've changed the voting laws
dramatically Pennsylvania there's a
lawsuit where they ruled the Republicans
and Democrats made an agreement on
voting changes that was ruled
unconstitutional recently so you you
we're seeing when you when you have set
on the throne of power
for 400 years
as white supremacy has sat there it's
hard to get off that Throne okay say as
you know some of us are musicians here
right so if you have a number one hit
number one on the charts you don't want
to see yourself fall down the number two
and number three and number four and
then fall off the top 100. you want to
stay at the top so when you when you sat
on the throne of power for 400 years and
I came here 400 years ago in 1619 all
right
and you know you you got you got a our
last president
set on the throne of power for only four
years and he thinks he's still there
it's hard to give up power but I I
you're operating under the pretext that
like what a lot of what we're seeing in
modern politics from Republicans is due
to them not wanting to lose white power
yes but where does that idea I'm not
saying just Republicans you know there
are racist Republicans and there are
plenty of racist Democrats okay do you
do you agree with um Harvard's
affirmative action plans
what are they so if I believe in
affirmative education I believe
everybody I don't believe in lowering
standards in order in order and having
quotas to get people you know up there
and lower the standard no I don't
believe in that at all but I do believe
in affirmative education giving
everybody an equal opportunity to get
educated so Harvard it's uh if you're
Asian you have to score I think 1300 and
if you're black or Hispanic you have to
score lower like eight or 900 on your
SATs or something like that so they make
it more difficult for Asians and they
make it easier for black and Latinos I
think that's wrong I I think they should
I just said that yeah yeah don't don't
lower the bar so this is the bar oh this
is this is the issue I'm fighting when I
say things like critical race Theory
should not be allowed in curriculum but
now let's talk about what you just said
okay so I I I I've sat there with
neo-nazis and KKK people Etc and I said
how can you hate me you don't even know
me
and sitting two feet in front of me well
Mr Davis you have to understand one
thing you know you know black you know
black people are prone to crime
and this is evidenced by the fact that
there are more black people in prison
than white people
what he's saying is 100 True the data
shows that the stat the statistics show
there are more black people in prison
than white people so what are you saying
is 100 right but so that justifies his
thinking you know we need to keep black
people down because they will the crime
will grow but
because it enforces what he already
believes as a KKK person or a Neo-Nazi
or whatever uh a white supremacist if
you just want to use the general
umbrella
um he is satisfied with that with that
statistic or that data he doesn't bother
to look behind the data and find out why
and why is it oh why is it because uh
black people tend to get imprisoned for
longer sentences than white people
committing the same crime when you find
a state like let's just say the state of
Maryland a few years ago well more than
10 years ago Governor Paris Glenn
Denning of the state of Maryland put a
moratorium on the death penalty as as
have a lot of States why because black
people were being legally executed for
their crimes where white people went to
prison for life or life with parole
okay so so what he wanted to do was you
know we want to put a 10-year moratorium
on the death penalty to study why this
is happening what the hell do you need
to study you know why it's happening
it's called racism white people have
been studying black people for 400 years
if you haven't learned anything in 400
years you're not going to learn anything
in 10 years I think I think class plays
a a big role in why we see the crime
rates the way they are I think people
who are in poverty uh you tend to see
higher crime in lower income areas it's
not absolute it's not the only reason
right but the the issue with um
uh black people in prison typically what
you'll hear from the right is I
shouldn't say the right typically you'll
hear from White identitarians is that
they commit a disproportionate amount of
crimes relative to other races
we hear that all the time but why they
don't have the opportunities and not
being given the opportunities why
because of racism now but that would be
that would be by class
it's by the fact that it's by color okay
it's by color I know both well it may be
class but you know as a black man I I
have experienced things that you guys
will never experience okay you know I
get pulled over 10 times more than you
do all right though huh do you I do yes
I do how do you know how many times I've
been pulled over I don't know but but
but by looking at you I can tell you I
have I have okay I reject that honestly
well then well then let's let's go let's
go and compare those times okay
and plus I've lived longer than you have
you have and you were around to be fair
considering you were around in in
pre-civil rights absolutely I've been
pulled over just for having a white
woman in my car
I've been uh I've been pulled over and
had cops plant drugs in my car I've I've
been pulled over completely illegally
like for no reason at all and then had
my license suspended how many times so
I've been pulled over illegally in my
life probably four or five times
that that's a drop of pepper in a salt
shaker how many times you've been pulled
over you can't even count the number
like well I was saying yeah absolutely
absolutely so and still today you are
you you are almost twice as old as I am
you were uh you've you've lived through
eras of you know pre-silver rights and
all that stuff so I I can't speak to
that but uh I I've I've been pulled over
and and I'm not trying to say that uh I
do what I'm trying to say is I don't I
don't respect you telling me you know
outright without actually listening to
me or knowing anything about my family
or my life or what we went through
through that you know outright I didn't
experience these things no no I didn't
say you didn't experience these things
or that no I said I've been pulled over
more times than you have it's what I
said and and I stand you are older than
me though it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter I'm also a lot darker than you
are yeah oh yeah absolutely and I and I
had okay listen
I I I I lived in a place called Potomac
Maryland
okay which tradition is an off-white or
a predominantly white uh area it's mixed
now all right my family was the second
black family to move into our
neighborhood my father was a senior
Foreign Service Officer my father was
Richard Nixon's interpreter when he was
vice president of the United States when
he went to Russia uh he was vice
president to Dwight Eisenhower he went
to Russia to have What's called the
kitchen debate with a Nikita Khrushchev
the famous kitchen debate my father was
Nixon's interpreter my father was one of
the first black Americans to speak
Russian all right fluently my father
spoke nine languages fluently all right
my father was one of the first black
Secret Service agents in this country
all right and then he and the Secret
Service would only let him go but so
high he did such a good job interpreting
Russian for Nixon Nixon came back and
told Eisenhower about him and Nixon and
Eisenhower called my dad into the White
House and Eisen Howard told my dad you
have gone as far as you can go in the
Secret Service you should you should you
should take the foreign service exam you
can go higher there so my dad took the
foreign service exam and became a
Foreign Service Officer but there was
still a ceiling for black people in the
Foreign Service but but let me let me
just finish okay so in Potomac Maryland
my dad had a Mercedes second black
family in the area my dad was getting
pulled over in our own neighborhood I
was a teenager what okay when was it
we were there uh in 1971 through
um see I still owned the house there but
um I I have another house where I live
um 1971 he died in 2018. so between the
uh more black people started moving in
probably in the mid to late 80s all
right uh they the cops thought my father
walked into the neighborhood and drove
out so when I turned 16 I got what all
black parents give their young boys it's
called the talk you'll have you heard of
the talk I had the talk too okay tell me
about it okay The Talk The Talk is what
black parents give uh six uh their their
young boys especially when they start
driving you know when you get pulled
over by the police even if if the cop is
wrong do not argue with them just take
the ticket sign it we'll go to court
we'll settle it in court because you can
get shot but but see this this is the
issue I have with I think what you're
saying is racist the the idea that black
people exclusively do that or it's
predominant among black people when
that's actually a normal thing most
people do no so perhaps it's a class
issue because my all of my friends and
myself had the exact same talk in the
exact same way I was told no matter what
happens when you're pulled over you turn
the light on you turn the car off keys
and wallet on the dashboard hands on the
steering wheel you roll down the window
and you don't move you answer the
officer's questions you do not argue
with him do you understand yes say it
back to me I'm sorry Tim but you were
100 wrong so but so it's it's just no I
I think it's fair to say that you're
older than I am you've we agree on the
racism of the past and I absolutely
agree well I completely we can agree on
the racism of the past but we can also
talk about the racism of today and I
agree a lot on it what I don't agree
with is that
this you know uh it's it's strange to me
to hear the idea of the talk perhaps
white Suburban upper class wasps don't
do that but growing up in in the south
side of Chicago in mixed race areas and
gang territory I'm from Chicago anyway
you're from Midway I'm from Chicago 500
East 33rd right on the south side right
yeah Midway so I'm on uh 47th 49th and
Laramie so I'm two blocks away from the
LeClaire courts I had to talk to my
friends all had to talk everyone had The
Talk The Talk existed among white kids
polish kids Mexican kids Asian kids and
black kids I think the nuances you have
the talk for the inner city kid what
every inner city kid's gonna get that
talk but you're saying in the suburbs
black kids get oh he's from the south
side of Chicago same as me but yeah yeah
but I but uh different parts yeah but
also um here well in Potomac Maryland
Lily white Potomac Maryland okay now
um sure enough when I started drive when
I turned 16 I was getting pulled over in
my own neighborhood all right
um I dated a woman in Luray Virginia Lou
Ray Virginia is like are you all
familiar with with Mayberry
no no okay
there was a TV show called oh yeah
called the Andy Griffin Andy Griffin
yeah okay and Mayberry was just you know
Little Lily White Town everybody knew
everybody real small town you know no
black people on the show and um you know
just super nice town that is Luray
Virginia you know you hear the Luray
Caverns Etc so I began dating a white
woman down there and um within two weeks
the Lou Ray City police who did not know
me from Adam
everybody knows everybody down there
went to her house
and told her
that I was a drug dealer and she said
why why would you say that no he's not
because he drives a black Lincoln Town
Car with dark windows
that was their excuse okay now but let
me get back to my conversation with with
the clan leader all right so he told me
I'm a criminal he didn't bother to look
in into the background as to why these
black people are in prison more so than
white people then he goes on to tell me
that um that that black people are
inherently lazy we don't want to work we
want to scam the government welfare
system we always have our hands out for
a freebie all right so now I'm sitting
here
I've been called a criminal I'm now I'm
being told that I'm lazy and then he
tells me and then I've heard this many
times thereafter from other clan people
that black people are born with a
smaller brain than white people
and the larger the brain the more
capacity for intelligence the smaller
the brain the lower the IQ and he says
that this is evidenced by the fact that
year after year after year black high
school students score lower than white
high school students on the SATs again
he is 100 percent correct black kids do
score a lot lower than white kids on the
SATs all right now
the data shows that so it it uh it
enforces what he already believes about
black inferiority so he doesn't bother
to look any further
but why is that well where do most black
kids go to school in this country in the
inner city where do most white kids go
to school in this country in the suburbs
it is a fact inner city schools are not
as good as suburban schools all right
there's not the opportunities there's
not the the textbooks the the quality of
teachers Etc I can guarantee you black
kids who go to school in the suburbs can
score just as high if not higher than
some white kids and white kids who go to
school in the inner city can score just
as low as some black kids if not lower
than others it has nothing to do with
the color of the student's skin or the
size of his brain but has everything to
do with the educational system in which
that child is enrolled I would also say
I'm pretty sure the brain things is not
true of course it's not ridiculous but
um I I find one of the things I find
interesting is that the inner cities are
all Democrat run and typically have been
for Generations Chicago for instance I
think for 80 years now or 100 years has
been run strictly by democrats who keep
promise listening to solve these
problems and never do so for me I was
just like these people are just lying
about everything and typically what they
do just makes things worse and then you
look at the suburbs and they have a
tendency to lean Republican or at least
they were for a while until Trump came
along to be honest and so I wonder why
it is that the political party that
keeps claiming well to be honest not 100
years ago but in the in the past 50
years these are the 60 years this is the
parties claiming to fight for the you
know the black community but continually
just just things can just get worse okay
New York New York's a great example New
York is Democrat Democrat Democrat
sometimes as a mayor who's Republican or
independent but it is overwhelmingly the
biggest Democrat stronghold in the
country and it's where you'll see bigger
cities biggest city big city for sure
but it's where you get stop and frisk
it's where you get the the complete
disproportionate cops will give a ticket
to a black guy drinking a 40 but they'll
not to a white person drinking wine I
mean these are these are liberal areas
well you know why why uh why there's a
higher penalty for crack cocaine than
regular cocaine right
was it more addictive no
because more black people use crap
cocaine because it's cheaper I wanted to
ask you more poor people use crack
cocaine in the past uh in the past 18
years have you ever been illegally
pulled over with drugs planted in your
car by the police no no illegally pulled
over yes drugs planted now so why is it
that I've had that happen to me and you
didn't
look
just just it was I mean in the past 18
years so um I I thought I was going to
have some plan at one time uh my band
and I were coming home from a gig and we
got pulled over and the cops uh figured
you know there had to be drugs and drugs
in the van because I have dark Windows
you know so people can't see in and see
the drum sets and the amplifiers and
whatever else is in there right
um so he starts making us pull out all
the amplifiers and he's like looking in
the back of the amps looking in in the
drum kits in the drum cases he was he
was not satisfied that there were no
drugs there he made us wait 30 minutes
what he called the canine a patrol
canine had to come and we all had to get
out of the van sit on the damn side of
the road while the dog runs through the
van sniffing for drugs so so and he
still didn't find any all right the dog
didn't find any and so I figured okay
this guy's not gonna give up he he's
probably going to plants on the end
there he didn't fortunately and then and
then he says okay uh you're free to go
and I said well why you know why'd you
go through all this and he says oh we're
training the dog that's [ __ ] when I
was in in 2012 I was in Chicago with a
group of friends and uh we had been uh
covering one of the protests there
at the end of the night I think we had
gotten some like Maxwell Street because
you know if you're from Chicago now it's
gone Maxwell Street is gone yes oh wow
well anyway we uh we got surrounded by
about 12 Vehicles some unmarked they uh
pulled inside the car at gunpoint and
did basically what you you described
they they pulled us all out they wrote
down our credit card numbers our IDs our
passports they started banging on
everything trying to pop things in the
car open and then after about 10 minutes
another cop shows up and he points to me
and we're on cuffs and he makes a motion
the guy uncuffs me and he says oh you uh
sorry you matched a description you're
no problem I got that all the time so
they also had raided the apartment we
were staying at and then they also uh
tried to get someone through what we
believe was a criminal informant to
plant drugs in our car but I wouldn't
let them they kept trying to get
Adderall from the basement and bring it
to the car and I told them if you'd go
anywhere near the department the cops
went in the apartment this guy was like
I'm gonna go inside real quick I said if
you go in there we're leaving you're not
coming with us and he's like but I need
a ride I'm like if you go in there and
you bring anything you are not coming
with us we found out later through a
series of text messages a person that
was dating one of the cops after getting
criminally charged with something
surprise surprise was telling him to put
Adderall in our car we were then told
that on the scanner they were describing
our vehicle and looking for us uh since
in the past 18 years uh I you know I
don't I don't really drive all all that
much anymore
usually other people are driving I don't
tend to drive other people drive uh so I
would say from like 18 to 25 when I was
mostly driving I had been pulled over
illegally maybe five times what I mean
by illegally is I've been pulled over
way more than that but pulled over
illegally is when there's no
justification for it and the cops would
make something up uh that was you were
swerving that was that was when they
planted drugs on me so I the only reason
I didn't go to jail when they planted
drugs in my car was because first what
they did was they they pulled me over
illegally and said uh the guy says I was
swerving but then goes oh whoa oh you're
smoking pot which I wasn't because I
don't smoke I don't have tattoos and I
barely drink I mostly don't drink and so
they out of the car I say okay because
you know I had the talk hands on the
steering wheel I get out of the car I
keep my hands up he immediately cuffs me
calls his partner his partner shows up
first thing he does is go to my car and
plant a nug of weed takes it out within
a few seconds and walks up to me holding
in his hand and says what is that and I
said I don't know and he says it's
marijuana and I said is it yours and he
says it was in your car I said no it
wasn't and he said confess that this was
yours and this will all go easier on you
and I said that's not mine and they said
confess that it was yours or it's going
to be worse and I said that's not mine
and then he makes a look he walks back
to my car the other cop starts asking me
a bunch of questions I very much I'm
just not saying anything I was about 19
at the time the cop walks back out
surprise surprise he popped up in the
glove box what did he find a firefighter
emblem my dad was a firefighter he said
who's a firefighter kid I said my dad
now the cop takes the Cuffs off go home
and they get in their car and they left
the only reason they didn't decide to
charge me with possession illegally by
planting drugs in my car was because
they found out that my dad was a
firefighter and there's like oh can't do
that I wonder why it is I experienced
that I wonder why it is that experience
the cops pulled me over at gunpoint I
wonder why it is that I was driving 10
miles under the limit on Lake Shore
Drive in Chicago when I was exiting at
Belmont Avenue which is a 45 mile an
hour speed limit and I get pulled over
abruptly as I'm exiting and the cop says
you are going 20 over and I said officer
I'm exiting and he goes tell it to a
judge and they suspended my license for
that I wonder why it is that I was
driving to O'Hare airport and I had a
cop nearly rear-end me and so when I
turned when I put on my signal to move
over the right lane he immediately flips
the lights on and said you started
speeding the moment I came up on you and
I said you you you nearly rear-ended me
and he says tell it to a judge and so I
end up losing my license for years why
did that happen to me was it because my
family was poor and we couldn't afford
lawyers was because my car was a piece
of crap 1989 Mazda 3 323 with rust all
over it was it because they saw me as a
poor person was because they were racist
and they saw me and just happened to
know what my race may have been I
honestly have no idea I I I don't know
why those things happen I don't doubt
anything that you said I've heard those
stories before some of them have
happened to me I've not been yanked out
of my car at gunpoint I've seen guns
before okay pointed at me but not like
that okay I've not had anything planted
in my car but I've seen all those things
happen and I I still to this day get
pulled over a lot look up okay speaking
of Chicago you probably never heard of
this guy but look him up John j-o-n oh
yeah you know him oh yeah we know I'm
not saying I'm not saying racism isn't a
real thing or that racism wasn't
affecting you I'm just saying
what what what you know ignites me in
this regard is when I'm told by someone
that I've had it worse than you because
of my race and it's like it may be that
you've had it worse than me but I I I
don't know I'm not saying those things
don't happen to you well sure but I
don't know if but this listen this
country is not only racist
but it's also based on a caste system
okay where lighter-skinned black people
get better jobs
all right dark the darker skin you are
the worse off you are all right I'm
darker than you are that's a fact we
can't we can't even argue that okay you
look at um for example you watch the
soap operas from the from the from the
80s and 70s or 90s whatever all right
basically they all were white it was
always a big deal when one of the soap
opera people on General Hospital or
whatever was going to have a date with a
black girl or some uh white woman was
going to have a date with a black man or
whatever that black actor was always
light-skinned all right to this day the
only
act black actress
who has received an Oscar
for a leading role leading role okay
is Halle Berry
Halle Berry is a very pretty girl
she's a very light-skinned black woman
all right
she is not the actress as say a Sicily
Tyson
was or or any number of other actresses
all right
there is a caste system going on I I I
agree with the caste system in a
different way I I can't speak to the the
skin color like the lighter skin like
I'm I wouldn't know well you know you
know I mean even during times of slavery
it was a lighter skin blast who got the
jobs in the in in the in the house I I
can say in Brazil yeah exactly yes it is
like I've been to Brazil Rio de Janeiro
Sao Paulo or Recife Bahia and Brasilia
tell you yes how it works absolutely so
there was an India too there was a story
a friend of mine who is a uh he is like
half native half uh European descendant
Portuguese and he was saying that he
once saw two black men fighting each
other over who was blacker as like an
insult to each other because that's the
culture they have I what I was what I
will say about the cast system you know
for me I think a lot of this has to do I
think class is the big ratio maybe maybe
it's because there's a generational
divide and your experiences can came
from you know very much more racist eras
and mine is coming from an era when a
lot of these laws are being started sort
of being taken away and stuff or for
whatever reason but uh I know people who
are rich because they're rich I know
people who
sell garbage to other rich people for
hundreds of thousands of dollars like a
piece of jewelry sold between rich
people is a is a is a net profit of 50
grand for one person a tax evasion my
friend well it's something and I'm just
I wonder why it is I'm like how do I
know people who do so little of anything
and they party in in in in Switzerland
and they party in the Mediterranean and
these on these yachts and these boats
and they'll be like well you know work
is hard I sell jewelry I make about 500
000 a year and I'm like why is why are
there Jewelers in New York making 50 000
a year just by virtue of being in the
higher class they have access to people
with cash and they make bigger deals
which Nets than bigger percentages so I
certainly think there is a class system
in the United States but I think the US
allows you to navigate it I think like
many other countries don't the U.S
affords the opportunity to figure out
how to how to work within the system to
manipulate and build your way up to get
out of these situations okay
you know back in the day
back in the day
when when black people were first you
know going to vote and all that kind of
stuff
most black people were Republicans did
you know that I mean the first uh the
first black Congressman was Republican I
think right you know why
why is that why did blacks join the well
first of all the Dixiecrats which became
the Democrats and stuff come up on the
mic um yeah they okay the Ku Klux Klan
was created by that party
all right so a uh that was a racist
party
blacks gravitated towards Republicans
because Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves
and Lincoln was the party of Republicans
so they grabbed they they admired
Lincoln went we went Republican all
right and that stayed for a long time
and then in the 1960s a vehement racist
named Barry Goldwater
opposed the Civil Rights Act and all
this other kind of nonsense and um you
know became pretty powerful
and blacks left the Republican Party
and went to the Democrat Party
Democratic party which became more
liberal and more accepting and more and
more racists began joining the
Republican party this is in the 1960s
all right and then it will flip back and
forth from time to time but that's how
it how it modulated when they say that
the parties flipped it's because of gold
water
in the 60s yes yeah I don't I don't know
if uh if I would look at what's going on
right now with Planned Parenthood and
with the Democratic party that they
flipped in any meaningful way if they
did I know it's it's argued the right
says they did and the left says they did
but I I look at as I mentioned Chicago
which has been under Democrat you know
rule or whatever you want to call it for
nearly 100 years I think I don't know
what point so you were making an issue
about about Planned Parenthood and you
were telling me about um Margaret
Steiner yeah yeah you didn't finish well
so she was a eugenicist she believed
Only the Good should procreate uh she
had a project that was called you see I
I hate how YouTube does this but I have
no choice but to call it the n-word
project it because but it's not the the
slur it was aceler and uh the goal was
to disseminate birth control and
contraception and and uh
you know trying to convince them not to
have kids for those reasons now there's
a debate on the quotes from this woman
because some of them are extremely
egregious and then the left claims
they're not real quotes so whatever I'll
leave that out of it I suppose but if
the goal of planned paranoid started by
this woman was to prevent black people
from having kids and to this day you're
you mentioned the white population is
decreasing but the black population is
stagnant it seems like her ideas to stop
black people from having babies worked
and now you can look at 2006 data I
pulled up that black women are five
times more likely to have abortions than
white women and this is preventing black
families and children from growing up it
sounds like these racists and the plant
Planned Parenthood is overtly you know
defended by the Democratic party which
was the party of racists they are still
enacting policies to hurt black people
when it comes to these like statistics
this is like black crime black abortion
whatever say that there's a five to one
ratio what is black crime let's yeah
exactly so in the past let's say for
every one white person that committed a
murder there were five black people when
they add the numbers up then what they
do is they project that past to the
Future they'll say so therefore black
people are five times more likely to
commit murder that no then the cops are
like I gotta look at every black guy
like he's five times more likely and
it's like we're creating a racist
projection
yeah just because it happened in the
past doesn't mean it's gonna happen I'll
tell you I'll tell you a funny story to
New York okay and then I want to go back
to the point I was making but uh there
was a black cop who went to Central Park
and started giving tickets to white
couples drinking wine and he said public
drinking is is a citation in New York
City and they got all banana shape and
angry it's hard to complaining and they
were like we're having wine at our
Central Park picnic how dare you and he
said white cops come to the black
neighborhoods and give young black men
tickets for drinking 40s on their own
Stoops and you're mad at me because you
were publicly drinking in a park and the
city admonished him and he got in
trouble for it I'm like that's
remarkable [ __ ] get me swearing on
the live show but uh I want to go back
to that point
because I'm curious as your reaction of
you know what we see out of Chicago for
instance it's not improved so I I used
to live where I lived was 49th and
Laramie are you familiar with the
Leclair courts no it's it's it's it's
it's fascinating and horrifying at the
same time familiar with Marquette Park
oh yeah yeah yeah in the history of
Marquette Park it depends on the history
I suppose I don't know Marquette Park
was originally very racist nothing but
neo-nazis in case okay people live there
you didn't know that no no no yeah I
mean American Nazi party was
headquartered there wow that wasn't that
far away I mean it wasn't that long ago
either right right right there's a so uh
I live on four ninth and Laramie
if you walk North two blocks you get to
47th Street which as soon as you crossed
it it was a hard racial segregation
everybody who lived north of 47th was
black everybody South was for the most
part it was mostly white like kind of
redneck you know we had Stickney the
suburb and so everyone there was kind of
just like low income you know white
people and then you had uh Mexican and
you had uh Greek no Polish Polish so
movini popolsku everywhere uh over on
Archer and we weren't allowed to walk
north of 47th because the police would
detain us they would they would say the
only reason you're here is for drugs get
in the car and they would take us back
and so it was fascinating to me that
there was this kind of soft enforcement
of segregation that there was a two
things happening there was a choice
people chose to racially segregate
people who moved to the area wanted to
live near people who looked like them
and that's what and like actually
started making prominent racial
segregation and then from there which
it's actually not necessarily from that
one point there's there's obviously
blockbusting and redlining before that
but then you'd end up with police doing
profiling though they they'd see you and
say what are you doing here get out
there were a lot of stories I'd hear
from uh White friends of mine like young
girls older black men would stop them if
they tried to cross 47th and they would
say young woman you best not come here
you need to turn around right now
because they would be in trouble the
black people well no no no because they
were worried about what would happen to
the white girls for coming into the
black neighborhood they were like
they're you know the segregation here
it's it was violent you know back in the
60s uh Martin Luther King himself said
Chicago was the most segregated City in
this country I think that's still true
so that you know what they did they did
they they destroyed the project housing
they just flattened it now it's Granny
green no this was uh I I don't know if
this is specifically the Leclair courts
because the Leclair courts Leclair
courts I think are a different it's like
it's there's a there's a there's a bunch
of project housing off of Cicero going
all the way down to Central Avenue in
Chicago I don't know if the entirety of
that was the called the Leclair courts
but there was an area of it but uh they
just flattened it all and it was crazy
when I one day I decided to look at a
Google map of my neighborhood and I saw
that all of the housing were uh like a
lot of the houses are still all you know
black owned black community but all of
the project housing was flattened and
their empty Fields with fences saying no
trespassing the city just came in and
just destroyed it and kicked everybody
out but see you know when people look at
that and they see this self-segregation
and they see that it works they think
it's the only way you know you know
there's no way people can integrate and
this is not true it's because
of the racism that has been perpetrated
and promulgated by this country it works
in other countries I saw it I was living
10 years ahead of my time when I was
overseas living in integrated
Communities going to integrated schools
in the 1960s not in my country but
overseas okay I was living 10 years
ahead of my time because 10 years later
there was diversity in my classrooms
here I know it can work but when you
don't travel you're not exposed to
different things you think you think the
world everything around the world is the
same way it is in your neighborhood you
know my favorite quote of all time is by
is by Mark Twain it's called the travel
quote and Mark Twain said travel is
fatal to Prejudice bigotry and and
narrow-mindedness and many of our people
need it sorely on these accounts broad
wholesome charitable views of men and
things cannot be acquired by vegetating
in one little corner of the Earth all
ones like it's so true man I went to
South America for I was there for like
five five months or something and I got
a taste of what it felt like to be the
other for the first time in my life and
I don't know if it was my race or just
the fact that I looked different but I
was walking you know people kept looking
at me and watching me and it was like
unsettling and I got it I was like wow
this is like what people in the United
States maybe feel like when when they
when they feel like in the minority of
the amount of people with a similar skin
tone or something like and it was just
so eye-opening and every I think
everyone's got to know they gotta know
that feeling I want to go to super chats
we'll go a few minutes over because we
went a few minutes over it's Friday but
uh um I'm gonna try and just find the
good core questions and I apologize you
know if we can't get to you but I wanna
I wanna tackle some the best questions
we can so smash the like button if you
do like the show I know a lot of people
are you know reading and arguing and
yelling at basically everybody but um if
you like the show and you appreciate the
conversations we have we respect we
appreciate it you can support us at
timcast.com but I'll start with this one
from patriot who said I'll say it again
the state of Texas isn't Who removed
slave from textbooks it was the Board of
Education dominated by leftists
I don't think you can answer to that the
statement I think but it does I do think
it highlights one of the issues is that
if you read a cursory story it'll say in
Texas they remove this word from the
books and then someone will say that's
not true it was the other side you know
how do we navigate when okay uh so I
mean I'm going to assume that whoever
said that is probably correct okay I
don't live in Texas so but the fact of
the matter is in the state of Texas the
word slave was removed from textbooks
but whether the state did it or whether
the board of education did it it was
done in the state of Texas but it does
matter who did it and why they did it
right right so no no no I'm talking
about as far as my point goes the state
of Texas removed the word slave from
textbooks in in Texas public schools now
who did it the Board of Education the
state government whoever he's probably
right okay maybe what the board of
education but it happened in the state
of Texas it didn't happen in California
or Nevada or Maryland or or New York or
or wherever no but I think the point is
that we agree the issue is when you when
you mentioned they put back enslaved
people I think no that they they
replaced it with uh immigrant worker all
right and then there was an uproar in
the black community how dare you you
know uh water down what happened to our
ancestors they were not immigrant
workers they were slaves so but is it
possible that in that Daryl is
misinterpreting the reason that it was
removed and that it was actually removed
by Pro critical race Theory people
that's that's the situation that's the
situation so so I think that like
removing master and slave from a coding
Library GitHub or whatever they're
getting rid of the word slave because
it's defensive to black people and it's
under the guise of progressivism and
critical race Theory they're doing it
you know see you know you want to blame
things on Democrats on on Republicans on
critical race uh proponents listen
at the end of the day you've got to
understand something this country was
built on racism racism still exists when
I was in elementary school we had slave
auctions but but you you would you would
never do that today they do it today
Progressive teachers a progressive
teacher just got fired for a white
Progressive teacher held a slave auction
amongst his students you meant like mock
in schools right yeah
no no no no no not mocking okay yeah I
think I read about that I didn't I
didn't read all this a mock as in they
they practiced yeah yeah yeah
exactly they were demonstrating
something okay but I'm talking about uh
they did it in my school I participated
in it okay as a kid it was a regular
thing to raise money
you know you know for for whatever
reason you know school trip or whatever
we would have slave auctions where kids
would bid on other kids you know it
wasn't like white kids bidding on black
kids you know I could bid on some white
kid or whatever all right and
um you you paid 50 cents or whatever and
that and and you bought that person and
that person had to carry your books
around all day well that's not the same
thing yes it is it was called a slave no
I'm saying what I was referring I know
what you're referring to you're
referring to a reenactment of a slave
auction it was a practitioner of
critical race practice who segregated
the kids by race and then made the black
kids wear shackles when I was in seventh
grade in 1992 in seventh grade Ohio uh
Cairo Falls Ohio we did this exercise in
like social studies class where we were
all plantation owners they were called
and we had to either get slaves or
indentured servants and then there was a
third type of worker that you would get
and you put these little stickers on
your board and everyone had their
stickers and you go around you trade
stickers with other people so I just did
the math and I was like well this is
cheaper than that so I got all the right
stickers and then won the the game but
it was just like indoctrination okay and
we weren't slave owners we were called
plantation owners right now do you
remember a lady named uh Jane Elliott
no okay you all need to look up Jane
Elliott brown eye blue eye
you all never heard of that experiment
hmm
yeah I think I may have heard of this
actually Jane Elliott she's a friend of
mine and she's still living a lot older
now
back in the 1960s
uh she's a white lady she took her class
of white kids
and she's separated all the brown eyes
from all the blue eyes and she told them
that the brown-eyed people were Superior
and blue-eyed people were inferior
and guess what the brown eyed people
started acting these little kids started
acting Superior all right and you would
see this this this you know this change
and then and and the and the blue-eyed
people were feeling inferior and and you
know being oppressed the next day she
flipped it around oh it's the blue-eyed
people who are supposed to be uh
Superior and the brown eyes were
inferior and they learned more about
racism from that and if you watch
interviews with those kids today as
adults they say I wish my kids could
experience that in school okay that's
Jane Elliott we'll read some more the
first thing I want to mention is uh
trock says where's James Lindsay
actually if you'd be interested I'd love
to have a James Lindsay knows more about
this stuff than certainly I do I think
it'd be a fascinating conversation if
you're interested sure invite me I'll be
happy to come back that'd be great we
should absolutely I think James is
probably I'm always ready to learn James
is going to be listening to this going
Tim no what you're wrong ah you've
missed this point and this quote let's
go and he's going to be saying things
like that all right so uh dragon
stallion says is that what it says
dragon's Talon oh
does your guest feel like black families
who own slaves also need to pay
reparations John casser was the first
lifelong slave in the U.S owned by a
black Plantation owner Anthony Johnson
do black families need to pay
reparations those who own slaves I
didn't say any families need to pay
reparations I say the government needs
to make those reparations okay the
people who own slaves are no longer here
I cannot fault you or you for what your
great-great-grandparents did all right
you need to know about it you need to
know it was wrong but I'm not going to
hold you accountable all right you're
not around you you were not around then
all right but government needs to make
those reparations and also it's possible
that their parents aren't even from the
United States well whatever I mean even
you know I know parents who who are from
the United States who did have slaves
not parents but their ancestors okay no
I'm not going to hold their descendants
responsible you know for sins of the
father or whatever you want to call it
no but the government needs to make good
on it but they never have that was a
straw man that was a straw man of what
Daryl said about reparations that you
know it's possible to have a nuanced
view about reparations that doesn't
involve throwing money around but does
involve something like Edge a major
education overhaul absolutely right
right but but hold on I mean 898 000
people gave their lives in this country
to end slavery and what's your point I
mean you mentioned the Japanese no one
paid like the reason they get paid is
because nobody gave their lives to stop
that it was wrong and they stopped it
you're you're this country is the one is
the country that won against slavery
that sacrificed nearly a million of its
children saying
you know let me tell you something
even today
when you go to schools in the North
when you study the Civil War
you are taught
the Civil War was fought over slavery in
the South no no no no it wasn't fought
over slavery it was fought over states
rights yes it was fought over states
rights the state's right to own a Slave
they don't put it that way but that's
what it was it's the same thing this
country is still fighting the Civil War
my friend I agree okay why are they
still flying Confederate battle Flags
even most young white people don't even
realize you know they don't call it that
down there I know they call the rebel
flag I know because they rebel against
against wanting to give up their sway
it's also if the Civil War is also
called The War of Northern aggression
right exactly I've heard that Lincoln it
really was an economic War for Lincoln
too he wanted he couldn't let the states
take all that money away from the but he
said the best way to Rally people is to
say it's about slavery and then he also
deep down wanted to end slavery so he
kind of tweaked the message
I've heard that I don't know but you
know they're still fighting that you
know you know fly flying um Confederate
flat Confederate battle Flags Okay the
the the crossbar and stars that you know
that you all call the Confederate flag
is not the flag of the Confederacy
that is the Confederate Battle Flag that
is the flag that flew in the Civil War
to battle to maintain slavery the flag
of the Confederacy are the red and white
stripes with the blue square with the
circle of silver stars that is the flag
of the Confederacy that crossbars and
stars is the Confederate Battle Flag but
a lot of people want to call it the
Confederate flag that's awesome yeah
that's true I just looked it up exactly
Okay so
so we have a few that are that are
bringing up uh French people owned and
sold slaves in Haiti and Mark says this
man has never heard of French colonies
or French Africa ask what happened when
French African soldiers were brought to
Europe in World War One the accusations
made towards them racism is the unknown
okay let me let me correct that man
right there and I hope you're listening
listen son I lived in French West Africa
for for uh for six years I lived in
Guinea I lived in Senegal both which
were colonized by the French so yes I do
know about French colonies
you're out to French into China Burma
I'll try to find another one I just look
at how the Europeans split up Africa man
they in the late 1800s early 1900s and
before that too it was just all it was
just a race to colonize and enslave the
entire continent so Colin Burke says one
of the bigger problems with reparations
that more than 80 percent of even white
people moved to the US much later after
slavery and half near the end of Jim
Crow so do you calm ancestors or
listen
but like I said I'll go back to my point
whether you moved here yesterday or
whether you moved here 500 years ago
nobody is still living today
who owned any slaves all right so I'm
not faulting the descendants of uh of
slave owners I am not faulting people
who came here yesterday I am faulting
the U.S government for not doing what
they what they were supposed to do they
gave Japanese Americans reparations they
gave Native Americans reparations they
they promised uh black people uh 40
acres and a mule and have done nothing
they haven't even apologized
that's what I'm holding accountable
the majority do you know what the
without looking it up do you know uh uh
who makes up the the majority of white
Americans in this country of what
dissent
Irish no no that was my guess no German
German Americans are are the largest
white majority followed by British
Americans oh yeah I'm German well I'm
American but yeah some some drunk boxer
was German in my history I think Daryl's
like envisioning of reparations is
actually much more moderate than people
might think in like in terms of pure
acknowledgment
I it seems like that's what you're
you're getting at Daryl like you're not
necessarily like people people like to
have different definitions of what
reparations are and you're more so
saying you just want clear
acknowledgment which you think well no I
want I want an apology
and I think people who have been
disenfranchised uh held back and things
like that should get something I'm not
saying throw money to them I'm saying
there should be government
vouchers for for education for two for
college tuitions things like that that
you know that that we were denied in the
past well so even even after slavery we
couldn't go to Princeton we couldn't go
wherever so you're saying based on a
race
based on race so what happens in say the
mixed race areas of south side of
Chicago when all of a sudden half the
people get vouchers and the other half
don't
they're all in the same neighborhood
same economic status if you are The
Descendants
of slaves you should be entitled to that
okay like if you are the descendants of
Native Americans you got 1 8 or 1 16 a
Native American blood in you you can get
something if you if you are a survivor
of the internment camps or your or or
your descendants are of the Japanese
internment camps you can get something
okay so descendants of slaves should be
entitled to what they were promised and
they never received just like
um the the uh the courts awarded the the
uh the survivors of the Tulsa Race
Massacre and their descendants something
and to this day they haven't got it so
so my question was what do you think
would happen to the mixed race
neighborhoods when only half the people
get vouchers get some kind of benefit or
resource nothing would happen why would
anything happen if if they're not
entitled to it they're not they're not
entitled to it should should I suppose I
suppose it's like wait a minute I mean
listen if somebody came over here
yesterday from Nigeria okay yeah he
looks the same as I do but he's not
entitled to what to what I do to what I
should get he didn't go through that his
ancestors didn't go through that okay so
it's just like you know somebody comes
over from from Japan tomorrow do they
get something that that's owed to to the
uh survivors and descendants of the
people from the Japanese internment
camps no let's say somebody is the uh uh
descendant of a a man and woman come
from Afghanistan with it with a child
after their country was completely just
destroyed and that kid isn't in living
in poverty in the neighborhood and then
all of a sudden the government comes in
and hands out checks based on a race
that they're not entitled to and they
say well your oppression doesn't count
because we're only talking about other
oppression the issue I have with
race-based distribution of resources one
the resource has to be paid for by
somebody the government doesn't have
money the government taxes the people
and then the P it uses the people's
resources to distribute where it wants
to I think the problem is the problem is
if we use race-based programs to give
people money it's just still yeah why is
it Tim that you know you haven't said
anything about that as far as Japanese
people go okay they're still getting uh
they're still entitled to money and they
but I did yeah hold on they can still
they can still get money Native
Americans to this day can still get
money okay
how come I can't get money okay not not
that I'm going to go to go look for it
or whatever okay we have been denied it
so you're okay with this group getting
it you're okay with that group getting
it but but now when it comes to black
people now you come up with all these
excuses about so-and-so died in the war
you know isn't that enough or no they
you know they should not get money
because this person isn't getting money
I didn't say it was okay that we're
giving people money based on race I
think it's wrong to get just I just I
literally said it was wrong Edition no
no no no no listen I'm not saying give
people money based on race
I'm saying give money people based on
the crime you committed against them
what if so like so so if they have one
ancestor who is enslaved
if they had one ancestor who was
enslaved are they entitled to it I would
say so yeah yeah but you'll end up
seeing a lot of white people get those
vouchers huh you end up with a lot of
white people getting those vouchers
there weren't that many white people who
were enslaved no they're but there are
white people who are the descendants of
slaves like if there was a a black slave
who found themselves in an interracial
relationship and now this person is
164th black or one eighth or one I mean
there there are people who uh a famous
actor I'm not gonna use their name who
is you know I think one-eighth black and
no one realizes it because he just looks
like a white guy but he'd get one of
these checks and he's a rich white dude
that makes sense it would you in order
to be consistent it would have to be
like that yeah the rich wife gets his
check too to truly repair system
which means to repair then I don't think
haphazardly handing money if people
don't we need to build holistic systems
that lift everyone up together like
decentralized technology and I'm not
going to derail guys into that don't
worry about it but I feel like when you
can do things that everyone benefits
from Clean Water Supplies and like free
internet access with satellites and
stuff like that then everyone has an
opportunity to better themselves you
can't throw eighty thousand dollars in
someone's face I just expect them to be
better I don't think Will Smith's family
should get free money should get money
from the government I just don't
understand it if he if if Will Smith's
family were descendants of slaves yeah I
I do and I think I think so should my
family we should we should we should
receive something for for the crime that
was perpetrated upon us that split my
family apart my ancestors would you know
we don't have nuclear families okay well
you're in name is Tim Poole where does
that name come from uh it's fake okay
well then
the lore of my family is that they were
uh
Bandits who created a fake name after uh
getting into a train robbery that
murdered somebody okay so
all right so we won't go there all right
so so Mr ottman here okay River Man
River man okay River man ottman where
does the name ottman come from
I actually well I can tell you one
interesting lineage fact uh I'm actually
so
my mother's name is ball middle name
maiden name ball George Washington's
mother Mary Ball so I'm actually uh
George Washington is my direct cousin
Seven Generations removed so that is
what it is it's a British ball is a
British name yeah but
I'm a mutt whatever okay so this man
right here can go to Britain and find
some balls
and find some people some balls who are
related I mean you know he will we're
kids we're children
there's a lot of them out there I'm sure
there are
I got a couple of them now
um he can go there and find some balls
that he is distantly related to all
right
My Name is Davis do you know where the
name Davis comes from Jefferson Davis I
have no idea okay Davis is a Welsh name
all right
do I look Welsh to you
no okay the name okay slaves took the
names of their plantation owners their
owners okay if they because the the
plantation owners could not pronounce
their real names number one all right so
you know the name Davis came from the
Davis Plantation in North Carolina all
right now if they did not like their
Plantation owner and most of them didn't
they took names when slaves were freed
they took names of people that they did
like or people who had higher uh
positions like presidents or free men
right and free men okay now
most people that you find that you see
today who are named Jefferson or who
were named Washington or who were named
Lincoln are mostly black people yes
there are some white Jeffersons you know
a few white people named Washington but
I'll guarantee you nine out of ten
people you meet with the last name of
Washington or Jefferson is going to be a
black person okay and they took that
name because their names were stripped
from them all right their their their
mothers and fathers were we didn't have
nuclear families okay I cannot you know
I I lived in West Africa I lived in
Senegal where Gore island is Gore Island
was where the slaves came from they were
locked up and chained in glory Island
put on the boat all right I've been to
Gloria Island I've seen those slave
quarters all right I cannot go to
Senegal or West Africa and find somebody
named Davis I can go to Wales I played
in Wales with my band okay and just for
fun I said anybody out there named Davis
half the people started screaming the
name Davidson whale else is as popular
as the name Smith is over here so I'm
like Hey cuz how y'all doing out there
you know so we were stripped of our
identity
we can't get that back but we are owed
something for the crimes perpetrated
upon us I'm gonna uh I'm gonna read uh
some critical ones I think some of those
were already critical but uh this one's
just overtly critical delhiopolis says
this conversation has been really effing
disappointing Daryl's Antics today have
done more to radicalize me than
de-radicalize me
well apparently he's already radicalized
I think that it's undeniable that this
is exactly the type of conversation that
needs to happen and the fact that you
know Tim you're getting like I saw the
splc thing coming out like for for for
them to accuse your show of
not having cross-spectrum conversations
is completely ridiculous this is that
well that's why the smear was like he
gets bad super chat sometimes and it's
just like the southern puppy loss Hunter
tried they don't like me either yeah you
know did you ever see uh my documentary
accidental courtesy no no oh you should
check it out I know that uh there are a
lot of people on the left who don't like
you yeah and I think I think it might be
because you've you've actually helped to
de-radicalize people I think these these
nonprofits that make money off racism
don't want racism to go away here's what
I think I think there's a generational
difference between us we've we've we've
talked to a couple other Boomers you
know uh in the past and it seems like
the way we consume as Millennials and
younger information you should ask that
guy why is he radicalized in the first
place I'd be interested in history well
it's because when you look at the the
older generation it seems like they've
abandoned the Millennials that's how it
feels I think to a lot of Millennials
they we recently had a guest who said
feminists are not pro-war and it's like
here we are as Millennials online
talking to Millennials and the feminist
Millennials are all overtly Ukrainian
Flags defending intervention defending
NATO's intervention and we're like we
don't want this
the Boomers in their world is completely
different
little stink bug yeah so I think for a
lot of people it feels like when we hear
from the older generation they're
detached from the world we live in and
they don't understand what we're
experiencing and so
it frustration yeah frustration funny
because you know you say that but I can
say the same thing
um you know being the older generation
from you guys you have no clue what we
went through yeah what I feel like
what's happening is you're exposing a
sort of Truth a perspective truth and
I'm reading this Galileo quote the truth
all truth passes through three stages
first it's ridiculed maybe you'll see
that in the super chats second it's
violently opposed usually you see that
in the super chats then it's accepted as
being self-evident okay so let me tell
you about Galileo and I'll tell you
about
um but before Galileo his um his mentor
his uh his person that he looked up to
was another astronomer who you've heard
of called Copernicus
all right
Copernicus said that
the Earth revolves around the Sun okay
that is a a heliocentric theory
the world
said no because you know we were
egocentric we thought we would the Earth
was the center of the universe and the
sun revolved around the Earth
and they call Copernicus a heretic and
they locked them up in prison for saying
that
guess what he was right a hundred years
later Galileo Galileo comes along
and he had studied Copernicus and
Galileo came to the same conclusion
that we are not geocentric we are
heliocentric all right and the Earth
revolves around the Sun
all right
they called him a heretic
but guess what Galileo was right
I want to read the Super Chat uh kid
funky fry says I think of my great great
grandpa who was blown apart to free the
slaves was payment enough especially
considering I or no one of my family has
ever owned slaves so there's a couple
questions I get out of this is
interesting so if this man is telling
the truth and his uh an ancestor died to
end slavery and his family never owned
slaves
if we do reparations should we also
create an exception that anybody who is
who is uh not descendant of slave owners
is exempt from the tax that would fund
their reparations
anybody who was who is not a descendant
of slaves would have a tax credit
exemption from any taxes that would go
towards reparations
I'd have to think about that but I but
you know it doesn't matter I I'm not I'm
not saying you know it doesn't matter
that his ancestors died uh fighting in
the Civil War okay you know you you go
and you fight for your country you go
and you fight for your land like listen
an American just died the other day over
in Ukraine okay that was his choice to
go there and fight all right uh so you
know does his family get some kind of
reparations you know I don't I don't
think so okay
we fought
against Japan
do do these people these people still
get uh reparations you know what why why
is it cut off uh when um when black
people don't get don't get any
reparations black people who are
descendants of slaves that is the racism
and I'm calling that guy who just wrote
you a racist
why is he racist why is he racist
because he doesn't he does not see the
racism that was perpetrated by his
country against people like me and my
ancestors thank you for your grandfa for
your great grandfather's service for
fighting in the civil war against
slavery but if you can't see that black
people in this country have not received
the the same
um apology for one and the same
reparations for another that Japanese
Americans have received and that Native
Americans have received something is
wrong you're blind Anthony saying that I
think he's just saying that
for you to say that he should pay I
didn't say he should pay what did I say
I said the government should pay but the
government takes money from him
listen we all pay taxes right so so if
we all pull our money together for say
the common defense and services and then
you step up and say I want to take from
that pool because of reparations he's he
says okay well hold on my my family
member died for you is is that enough
you say no you're a racist I think
that's I mean you can't you also just
because your anti-reparations does not
mean that you're racist there are many
black people who are no no no he didn't
say anything no I'm not talking about
him I'm just I'm saying for you to call
him a racist when he's simply saying
don't take for me
I'm calling him a racist and I'm
standing behind what I say and listen we
all have to pay taxes when you drive
down the road
you are not allowed to use the HOV lane
if you don't have two people in your car
or hov3 three people in your car if
you're riding by yourself
and you drive down that lane you will
get a ticket if a cop sees you all right
I I've done that and I've gotten a
ticket all right not because I'm black
but because I was driving down the HOV
lane with one person me in the car all
right guess what I pay taxes and my
taxes built that road what if he says
why can't I use that lane can he get
reparations for his great grand great
great grandfather dying
should the government pay him for the
loss of his grandfather I right now I'm
talking about
black
descendants of slaves okay now if he
wants to get reparations from from the
government because his great great
grandfather died you know that's his
fight convince me and I and I will stand
behind him but do you think that if he
went to the government and said I should
and the government said yes and then
they took tax money and gave it to him
tax money that you pay would you be okay
with that
not if I'm not getting any reparations
no well then why should he after his
father died
you're missing the point well because
when it comes to getting black people
something
you all are saying no cut it off here
we're not that's not [ __ ] because
you you've already acknowledged Japanese
Americans are getting it uh Native
Americans are getting it so what is the
problem I said it was wrong well what is
whether you say it's wrong or nothing
racial disbursement of money hold on
whether it's whether you say it's wrong
or not it's happening what are you what
are you doing to stop it
I do a show where I say it's wrong oh
that's not stopping it is it I mean I
vote it inspires other people to vote it
has an influential impact on people
sharing ideas
to us
once once everybody okay should the
people who who um first first of all
should the descendants of the Tulsa Race
uh race riot the the Black Wall Street
descendants should they get reparations
from the people who committed the
atrocities maybe people in that people
who committed the atrocities are dead so
then what do you do
do you punish the living descends of the
father see the issue I have with this is
that did I say punish what did I say
specifically the sins of the father who
is paying for it who takes the U.S
government pays for it whether it comes
out of your taxes or whether it comes
out of their Fort Knox or wherever it
comes from the U.S government it would
be the Federal Reserve they'd print a
bunch of money and then it would have
caused inflation right right I think why
they haven't done it before yeah well
well you know what why didn't people
think about that before when uh when
when they were murdering uh Indians and
murdering but those things are all bad
like yeah yeah but the point is but the
point is you keep driving home this is
where I draw the line you know what
you're saying Tim is racist whether you
are or whether you're not I think it's
racist well that's fine you can do
whatever you want to think I don't care
my point is when it comes to uh
uplifting black people the line is drawn
nobody stops nobody said that did I say
anybody said it you said we all did
several times I said what you're saying
is wrong I said when it comes to
uplifting black people the line is drawn
when it comes to uplifting this person
or that person that person I was already
been done I wasn't alive done I wasn't
alive it doesn't matter whether you were
alive or not what happened so I wasn't
alive when they interned Japanese people
my family actually suffered because I
come from an Asian background and they
were spit on and treated horribly no
doubt and uh the only thing I can say is
that I was born into a world with
problems and we advocate for solving
those problems but I don't think that
racial policies solve those problems I
think that's what we're fighting against
yeah we're fighting against the
government creating racial segregation
because we want people to come together
and live together and work together and
so what we end up seeing is okay so how
do people come together when this person
has ten dollars and that one only has 50
cents
this is why I said I think it's a
problem that they disperse money based
on race I wasn't alive when they said I
didn't say disburse money based on race
I said dispersed money based upon those
people who suffered from crime due to
racism but that means white people a lot
of white people a lot of white people
committed those crimes no they'll get
the money
a lot of white people who are overtly
white with blonde hair and blue eyes
still have slave ancestors I'm not
saying Millions that's fine but I just I
just don't agree with giving white
people reparations oh you want to give
people opportunity not money money could
be part of it did I say money okay I
know what you said it doesn't happen
resources like the idea that we're gonna
try and like
you're going to see some you know rich
white family who's like you know
actually one of our ancestors was a
slave we're 1 64th and that person was a
part of our family and then all of a
sudden this waspy family is like getting
a voucher for college yeah that's what I
want to avoid I think that the only way
we can do it is uplift everyone together
I think if you can create software or
some sort of technology that allows
people with or without money to create a
business to start their own
entrepreneurial ship and get
subscriptions from people then you're
uplifting everyone because a lot of
times it's the poor that are suffering
right now it's like you said you
wouldn't take money if there was a
system like this where they're handing
out checks or you just said earlier you
wouldn't I don't know right because you
don't need it but these people don't
need it they need opportunity well what
about what about uh tax credits what
about like a tax a break or something
like that there are many different
things that can be
um given in in lieu of of money maybe a
tax credit maybe a tuition you know I'd
have to think that through or have other
people who have more intelligence than I
do think it through all right but
something needs to be done and nothing
has been done for for the descendants of
slaves that is my point okay something
has been done for the descendants of
Native Americans something has been done
for the descendants of Japanese
Americans but when it comes to people
who look like me the line is drawn we
have never even received an apology for
slavery telling me slavery is wrong well
[ __ ] so what okay yeah it's wrong but
telling me we're sorry it happened is a
whole different thing is affirmative
action
something to assist in this in this way
it's it's it's overtly race-based uh
affirmative action has many different
definitions just by critical race Theory
I don't like I said before with
affirmative action I do not believe in
lowering the bar of Standards I believe
in keeping the bar up and people aspire
to hit that bar not lower the bar so
people can reach it keep it up I believe
in affirmative education where everybody
has the opportunity to better themselves
and go out and get better jobs okay as
you mentioned give people opportunities
they don't have the opportunities if
they if they're not educated when I
think about it and even even those
people who are educated like myself okay
I still experience discrimination when
it comes to jobs
yeah people need to learn how to run
their own business as a young kid
regardless of where they go to school or
their age or any of that stuff people
need to learn that stuff you know when I
think about apologizing for slavery I
have a hard time be doing it for real
because it's horrible like to enslave
humans is horrific the uyghurs in China
That's horrific that this computer was
made by slaves in part but like if it
hadn't happened the way it happened we
wouldn't be here and that I like that
we're here so I wouldn't change it I
mean maybe if I could go back and say no
it wasn't a slavery maybe it would have
been conquered by you know the Mexicans
or the Portuguese or like who knows
where we'd be so it's that's why I have
a hard time just outright giving like a
genuine like I'm sorry it happened
because it didn't happen to you
um so I want to apologize to if I saw
somebody I don't know man
let me let me give you an example of
something okay
true story
I was giving a lecture at Michigan State
University some years ago in Lansing
Michigan all right and um this white
girl you know we're talking about
apologies and stuff
and she says you know why should we
apologize no she's she was not a racist
okay what she was saying was racist but
she was not a racist I could see that
she was like why why should we apologize
I mean I wasn't around when slavery was
happening nobody in my family owned
slaves why should I apologize for what
my great great ancestors did you know I
I wasn't responsible for that
and I said
the apology is symbolic nobody is around
all right yourself you know you give
medals posthumously it's symbolic all
right people cannot move forward until
they have received an apology for
wrongdoing to them and I said to her I
said listen it was in November when I
was lecturing out there
um I said okay let's say I'm a student
here at uh at at uh at Michigan State I
said and I live in the dorm and I and I
live you know on the East Coast
you live here in Michigan and you said
and you and I are friends and you say to
me hey are you going home for
Thanksgiving and I say no I I can't
afford to go home for Thanksgiving I'm
going to save my money and go home for
Christmas vacation okay and then and
then you tell me oh well you know my my
grandparents told me you know if I
wanted to I could ask some of my
students you know who weren't going home
if they want to come over for
Thanksgiving dinner you know would you
like to come and I said sure okay so now
I'm invited to her grandparents for
Thanksgiving so she comes by my
dormitory picks me up takes me over to
her grandparents house along with some
other students now let's say her
grandfather didn't realize that she was
going to bring a black student home this
guy's a little older he makes some
racist remarks or whatever that offends
me
I said to her I said what are you going
to say to me
on the way back to the dorm and she said
I'm gonna say I'm sorry about what my
grandfather said I said but you know
what you didn't make that remark your
grandfather did you are apologizing for
your ancestor I said it now I said I
can't change how your grandfather feels
okay but I appreciate the fact that you
acknowledge that it's wrong and you say
you're sorry I got apology to confront
the grandfather as it happens and be
like dude we're in the 21st century grow
up look at the eyeballs
I want to read some more Super chats so
there's a bunch that are saying very
similar things so I I'm not going to
read I'm just going to give the general
ideas there's two uh interesting ideas
um many people have said that they think
you're a racist fine and uh a couple
right here we have one from Kyle we have
one from Kevin D
uh who both said I'm white uh Kyle says
white dude I've had the talk I'm pretty
sure everyone has the talk Kevin says
I'm I'm white grew up in the middle
class family in a suburb in Los Angeles
and I had the talk and others have said
that
they think your view of the talk being
explicitly a black thing shows that
you've been I didn't say explicitly we
decided something that black families do
I said black families do it and say
explicitly what's your word well so the
general idea that I guess people
absorbed by that is that you think it's
exclusive
listen
I never said it was exclusive but I
didn't use the word exclusive I didn't
use the word I said black families give
their boys when they turn 16 something
called the talk I said black families do
that did I say did I say black families
do it exclusively did I say black films
do it right explicitly no I did not so
that guy is is putting words in my mouth
well no no what I guess the idea they're
conveying is that when you say black
families do it they interpret you as
saying as if it's not happening
elsewhere guess what black families
listening to James Brown does that mean
no white people listen to James so okay
so so the black families exclusively
listen to James Brown well so you're
clarifying I'm clarifying I'm I'm
clarifying his BS that's what I'm I'm
calling BS on him now
hold on hold on let me tell you about
the talk okay the talk that that black
kids get is the one that I described
about the same one that you describe
about Keep Your Hands on the Wheel don't
argue sign the ticket we'll fight it in
court okay otherwise you know you could
come home in a box all right now a lot
of white people get the talk but most of
the of the white people that get the
talk is a different talk how do you know
because I have a lot of white friends
okay who tell me so all right I have a
lot of black friends who tell me well
that's fine okay that makes sense but
hold on that makes no sense you haven't
even heard what I said yeah based on a
race huh you're generalizing based on a
race you just said you had a lot of
black friends I was making a sarcastic
point to counter your racist point you
haven't I know you haven't even let me
finish my point okay so hold on hold on
I'm gonna finish my point okay a lot of
white kids get the talk but it's not the
same talk as the black kids get to talk
because they don't have the same
experiences the talk that though that a
lot of the white kids get is when they
start driving
don't get pregnant don't come home
pregnant use condoms you know I don't
want to be a grandfather or grandmother
before my time I think that's the talk
that a lot of white kids get now I
challenge I challenge you hold on I
challenge you to you say you have a lot
of black friends no no no no hold on I
know well maybe you don't have any but
but fine but find some okay okay
I wanna I'm going to clarify that when
you made a racist generalization I made
a sarcastic Point what was my racist
General generalization you have a lot of
white friends therefore you know what
white people in general do did I say I
know what white people in general yes
you did I said I said most white kids
get this talk now they say all white yes
they do you don't know yes they do yes I
do no you don't yes I do did you grow up
in a white family in a suburb I grew up
in white neighborhood I went to White
schools
saying us to us right now it's not their
experience you say Well they're racist
and wrong I didn't say they're a racist
you certainly said this man was racist I
said what he said was racist I didn't
say he was a race
no Daryl I haven't spoken in a while I
need to say something seriously
we need to stop overtly calling people
racists I will call a person a racist if
I see that they know well I'm just
saying I'm just saying at this table I
know and love you all and I know for a
fact that nobody at this table is a
racist a hundred percent maybe certain
racial comments can be made but I know
that for a hundred percent like a
hundred percent so so the fact that like
these names are getting thrown around I
just I don't think it's really
productive I'm not saying you can't call
someone racist I'm not saying racists
don't exist I'm but I think we need to
be very careful all this dude said as a
white dude I've had the talk I'm pretty
sure everyone has the talk well see he's
pretty sure everyone has to talk talk so
now you're going to defend him he's
pretty sure everyone has the talk but
yeah when I you accuse me of saying all
white people and now I'm a racist and I
don't know [ __ ] but he says everyone and
you're not defending him well let me
explain when he says everyone he means
you too
ever everyone has to talk I know a lot
of people haven't had the talk well sure
a lot of white people haven't had the
talk for sure but but now you're just
getting semantics no no I I I'm I'm
reacting to what he said so they said
everyone and you didn't get on him but
you got on me for saying a lot of white
people because I don't like the racist
generalizations like I don't I don't
like it when someone says this country
is based on race okay there is only
listen I believe there's there is only
one race it is a human race okay One
race you and I are the same risk Ian and
I bill and I are the same race we all
are the same race the human race but
this country has divided Us by color and
if you don't believe that you need to go
back and learn your history which you
apparently have not learned if you don't
see that and if they don't see that this
country is predicated on Race but we
this country was built on white
supremacy we're we're on slavery at the
bottom so I think a lot of people
especially me we agree with you with
like so much of the historical problems
and racism and civil rights and all that
stuff but you think it's all over no I
literally said that wasn't
so what's your point so when you say
something that is dividing People based
on race and people take issue with it
you you you recoil you call them races
do you not see this country dividing
People based on race you think we live
in a post-racist society because we had
a black president or something a lot of
white people think that too I've heard
I've heard white people say racism is
over you know we've had Obama
well but we're not saying that I'm
saying you know one of the one of the
things that I'll just say triggered me
was this idea that there are certain
things you've suffered that are either
described only as a black experience or
in this instance when people felt when
you said black families give their kids
The Talk The response was them saying
I'm white and I've had the talk and some
people saying they feel like that was
you showing you're radicalized to a
racial as a racial component well that's
pretty that's pretty stupid and that's
pretty racist so I just called somebody
stupid I just called them racist so now
hold on I can speak as a black man so
why is it when I say
um I as a black man got the talk I am
racializing something I am black that is
my sad white people do acts and you're
not a white I didn't say white people do
X I said I did I said I'm black people
have a different talk they do this they
do you can't speak as a white person can
you I can speak I can repeat what white
people have told me are you denying that
white people have told me that are you
calling them Liars I that's not no I'm
asking you that question that has
nothing to do no no answer yes or no are
you calling the my white friends liars
I'm calling them anecdotal anecdotal so
so you're saying that that that they
they did not have the talk that I told
you that they had no no anecdotal means
you heard I know what anecdotal means so
the issue is if you have your stories
and they have their stories it's a moot
point meaning no it's not about some
white people experience the talk in
great degrees have you experienced
everything I've experienced no no it's
no what you're saying yeah dude it's
evidence what you're saying is evidence
and then what these guys saying is
evidence none of it proves anything but
we're all given our anecdotal levels it
doesn't prove anything well like our
statements today us we whatever you say
whatever I say it doesn't prove it it's
just a piece of evidence towards the the
postulation I don't understand what you
mean it doesn't prove anything if I tell
if okay okay so he tells me that he got
pulled over at a gunpoint and he got
handcuffed and some guy tried to plant
Adderall in his car
I just said it's a moot point it you
know it didn't happen it's just oh no
well that would be evidence that there
is more crime towards people like him in
that area or something it wouldn't prove
that it's always more crime towards
people like him in that area it doesn't
prove it but it's evidence suggesting
that it's real and I think you saying so
Justin that is real it is real he
experiences
on video or not
I believe it happened to you because
that crap was happening long before you
were born so okay so I don't need the
video so I know that you know why I know
it happened because it happened to me
not at gunpoint similar things I've been
hearing about that [ __ ] long before long
before video before anybody had video
camera so other than TV stations when
you say you experience something like
the talk or a white person told me the
talk and then a white person from their
own personal experiences say that this
is what happens to me why would they be
wrong or racist did I say they were
wrong listen there are white people yes
who get the top Keep Your Hands on the
Wheel you know don't argue with the cops
whatever all right
but there are also plenty of white kids
who get to talk don't come home pregnant
use condoms all right we get to talk
when we get stopped by the police when
we start driving
obey the speed limit don't do anything
to raise suspicion to cause somebody to
pull you over because here he hold on
hold on let me say something that
doesn't happen other people like it does
not happen with the frequency like I
told you hold on hold on I'm telling you
the frequency okay which you what you
debated with me and was the first time
you called me a racist I told you that I
have been pulled over more times than
you have and I have whether you whether
you want accepted or not that's
objectively true you're older than me
too it doesn't matter I still have even
if you and I were the same age okay in
the last five years yes yes okay yes now
I want you to do something both of you
and you too if you want here's an
experiment okay you said you had some
black friends I assume you do you also
have some white friends I want all of
you alone ask 10 of your white friends
male friends
what is the first thing and you people
out there listening you do the same
thing as ten of your white male friends
what is the first thing that goes
through your mind when you're driving
home late at night let's say two o'clock
in the morning whatever from a date or
from getting off work whatever
and and you see those those lights come
on in your re in your rear view mirror
those flashing lights you're being
pulled over maybe you're speeding maybe
you weren't maybe you cross swerved
whatever maybe you didn't whatever
you're being pulled over what's the
first thing that goes through your mind
I will bet you
10 out of 10 or 9 out of 10 of those
white males your friends are going to
say I hope I don't get a ticket I hope I
don't get uh points on my license I hope
my insurance doesn't go up you asked the
same question the 10 of your black male
friends
they're not gonna say anything about the
damn ticket or points on the license or
Insurance they're going to say I hope I
don't get shot I hope I don't get beat
up because they're because there is a
more frequency of violence against black
male drivers than white male drivers
okay just like there is more of a
frequency of blacks being sentenced to
death and and whites for the same crime
get to go to prison for life or life
with parole okay that is called racism
and that's why black people get that
talk I'm not saying white people don't
get the talk but black black people's
lives are more in danger and that's why
black lives matter was uh was created
okay I'm not saying I I'm a proponent of
of that movement or whatever I'm just
telling you why it was created okay
because of of the things that were
happening to black people where they
were not happening to white people in
the same
um uh situation well black lives matter
was started over Trayvon Martin that's
right and Zimmerman's a Hispanic guy
and the uh Zimmerman he is of Hispanic
descent but Zimmerman enjoyed what is
called White Privilege that's critical
race Theory the idea that is your
definition of critical race Kimberly
Crenshaw I I can pull it up right here
for you listen that's your definition of
whiteness as property in which she
described how passing led to benefits a
kid to owning property yeah this is this
is uh this is Cheryl L Harris in the
Harvard Law review and uh Citation for
it is Crenshaw at all 1995.
so
um this idea that because Zimmerman I
mean I disagree I don't think he looked
what I think it looked like a Mexican
guy and uh further the news lied about
what Zimmerman did NBC edited his phone
call to make it seem like he was
racially profiling when he wasn't so the
narrative that emerged from that was
actually fabricated okay do you remember
well you're probably too young for that
but but you know about it the O.J
Simpson trial yeah
do you remember OJ's picture on the
cover of Time Magazine and Newsweek no
okay well then you guys need to research
that okay
Time Magazine at Newsweek magazine came
out the same day
Time Magazine intentionally darkened O.J
Simpson's picture darker than his skin
tone because the blacker you are the
more evil you are there you go wow that
is racism yeah I don't give it but man
what do you all say you can call it a
critical race Theory you can cook
whatever the hell you want to call it
that is racism that is what this country
is predicated upon to turn white people
against people of Darker skin and that's
why I get pulled over more than you and
more than you and more than than your 10
white friends but Newsweek didn't darken
his skin
well I can't tell
listen you know you can argue all you
want there's your picture right there
one one is showing
one is showing O.J Simpson uh in his
real skin tone and the other one is
showing him darkened and Time Magazine
did that intentionally but Newsweek
didn't
I don't know if they did or not but look
at that yeah okay that that's how I know
O.J Simpson I don't know in person I
think that's garbage I think the media
is overtly racist and trash I think they
employ some of the most vile racists oh
now oh whoa whoa you're saying all media
oh my goodness oh yeah oh no no it's
like this Council on Foreign Relations
you're the media you're the media yeah
for sure I'm not calling you a racist I
don't think everybody here is racist no
I you know I'm I'm just so disdainful of
corporate press so we usually the
colloquial so is everybody is everybody
at Time Magazine responsible for that
yes really oh
I'm not going to swear even even the
peons yes no not the cheap workers some
brainchild if you guys listen to this
show you know my position on all of this
if you stand beneath the infrastructure
holding it up as they do things that are
wrong and you know they're doing it
wrong I will hold you responsible you
know the Chinese have this term called
biteswa which means white liberal like
that's a white left white left which is
inherently I feel like a lot of this
racism is being seated like it didn't up
until I'm not saying it didn't exist but
in like the early 2000s it felt like
there was a we were coming together it
felt like it I felt like it did you feel
like it in that yeah I I see progress
all the time okay I think right now
right now uh there are people who would
disagree with me
but I would say right now is one of the
best times in our country even though
we're so divided all right because uh
the wool is being pulled back the carpet
is being pulled back and we're seeing
all the dirt people are are saying how
they feel what they're thinking Etc it's
hard to address something when people
are hiding in the closet or hiding
behind a smile and stab you in the back
right now people are expressing their
views it's very divisive but this is the
best time because now we know what
people are thinking we know how to
address them rather than be a a uh what
do you call it a wolf in sheep's
clothing okay YouTube literally just
deleted all of the super chats oh yep no
no kidding the only ones that are up are
the ones that are in the active chat so
I'll see what I can um whoa how did I
delete them no no YouTube just just went
there were probably has that ever
happening before no wow yeah what
happened so the the paid comments where
people are asking questions just crashed
they're gone why I don't know oh I've
never seen it I'll just say it was a
browser error I suppose but I'm still
I'm still seeing him come in I can see
him come in and I can see the ones that
are over the chat but I can't see um any
of the other ones and I don't I don't
know how much more more time we have uh
I don't have a whole lot I gotta go out
of town tonight all right all right so
um sorry guys YouTube Just nuked your
super chats uh
I suppose we'll just read a couple more
but uh I think people are
unhappy with uh your views just just
well you know what people have been
unhappy with my views for 400 years
so I'll read this you know BlackRock
beacon says Daryl is done he has
abandoned nuance and critical thinking
and has become emotionally defensive and
lost empathy he is literally starting to
rant when pressed with logical arguments
this he's entitled his opinion and
that's fine I think that people need to
recognize that the conversation is
happening and everyone's in a different
spot on it and Daryl is extremely
pro-free speech vastly more than many
people sort of in the critical race
Theory realm and that I absolutely
appreciate that and a lot of people
won't come on the show to talk so that
matters someone just mentioned that the
the the chat was gone too oh it's bad
I'm watching it live right now sir did
you see the chat disappear at all no
someone said YouTube wiped the whole
chat not just super chats okay
um yeah this kind of surprise this kind
of conversation is hot I mean that's the
reason why
that's why it's good because now it's
people like this guy criticizing me is
Twitter Express his view I'm free to
express my view you can think whatever
he wants to think about me I'm fine with
that I I've been you know called every
name in the book and you know I've been
called every name but my own and that's
fine okay he's he's entitled to his
views I'm entitled to My Views okay and
you know like like you guys never saw
those pictures before why is that where
are you too young no no no not because
you're two years you haven't done the
research they're there they're there go
back and connect the dots Tim you know
you're talking from a bubble man you're
not talking from the generation moving
forward yeah exactly so so we got to
bridge that Gap and that's why I'm here
but I think that's the dots for you as
to why I've arrived at this point right
so I think the issue we experience is
that the world and uh the information we
consume as Millennials is so vastly
different from yours that we see it's
literally two different universes
but you know what figurative you are you
are here figuratively different
universes whatever Universe you're in
is because of the Universe from which it
came
but you don't look back
to see where you came from I mean I took
a point about the show of the one story
it doesn't mean I'm talking about his
story you're talking about history his
story like who's who's controlling his
story who's writing it so like your idea
I've got a Life Magazine from 1944. I
picked up in an antique shop and I've
also got one from the 1950s and I think
it's got uh who's on the cover is it
Winston Churchill Nixon doing a peace
sign for a big crowd and it's talking
about the Civil Rights Movement it's
fascinating to read the 1944 uh it was
March just before D-Day couple months
and the explanation for why U.S forces
were in Britain is like laughable it's
like well now we know but when you read
stuff in the past it's amazing what
people thought about this stuff how
information was being withheld but I
think what's happening is for most of
the people who watch they're that are
are the bulk of our viewership like 60
70 are between 18 and 35. so the news
that they're reading is rapid and
they've probably heard everything you've
mentioned no it's but it but well when
you have when you when you live in the
digital world and it's and it's and they
have access to everything a hundred
thousand tweets every single day that
you're you're being slammed by it's very
different so I think you know we see it
with Bill Maher
we've seen it with our other uh guests
who are in The Uber generation that the
the rate of information consumption for
the older generation is substantially
slower based on just the the traditional
information gathering practices of the
previous generation relative today so
these younger people right now as you're
saying it are Googling it in real time
and they're commenting saying you're
wrong about this and so that's one of
one of the challenges we have why we
have to be walking on ice and making
sure we're doing the best is that the
the 50 000 people concurrently watching
at any moment are all sending the
real-time fact check because they can
research exactly what we say so most of
these people no no as far as I'm telling
me that I'm wrong
I don't believe that they are
factual they're telling me that they're
that I'm wrong based upon their opinion
and what they think about what I'm
saying that's fair but like a good
example is the Kimberly Crenshaw thing
who explicitly wrote that race Marxism
and all that stuff I don't have a laptop
in front of me okay but I can send you a
link to Kimberly Crenshaw talking about
what she means by quick race Theory and
the same argument that you gave that she
uh refutes I mean and I I will send you
that link like I just read her book I
read I read the first I read the
introduction to her book so what you
know I mean she recanted her book I mean
that'd be fantastic we can talk about it
I don't know if you recounted her a book
I know what she said on live interview
okay you can see her talking okay yeah
people people say you know listen people
have done interviews with me
and and have gotten it wrong okay
um for example I won't I won't name the
school uh a very famous uh University
hired me to come do a lecture all right
and this guy uh called me before the
lecture and wanted to know if he could
interview me before I could before I
came well when I came down before I gave
the lecture from the student paper I
said sure I said but are you going to
stay for the lecture because I want you
to see the lecture as well and then you
can interview me after as well he said
okay so he um he interviewed me when I
came down to the uh to the university
Good Guys good lecture give me good good
interview and and he stuck around
watched the lecture asked me a few
questions afterwards
the next day
headline in this famous university paper
uh first black member of the Ku Klux
Klan speaks on campus
now he did not write that that caption
that headline that was done by the
editor of the paper or whatever you know
the campus had an uproar and they had to
make them you know make a retraction
there are no black members of the clan
if there were black members of the clan
there wouldn't be a damn Clan
okay but you know people get things
wrong in writing I can show you a link
of her talking now whether she wrote it
in the book and then changed her mind or
whether the book got it wrong or
whatever I I will send you a link to her
talking answering the exact question
that you said which is opposite of what
the other guy says I do think I've I
watched her give uh uh given several
interviews yeah but you know I'm pretty
sure I've seen a bunch of them I suppose
the issue is just um
what she wrote in her books versus what
she says today may be different listen
George Wallace do you know who he is oh
yeah okay and you know what he did he uh
School segregation and Right Stuff
segregation today tomorrow and forever
stood in the in the door wouldn't let
the uh the black kids come in National
Guard had to come and pull him out of
the door okay
he got shot I watched him get shocked
wow I watched him get shot on live TV
okay uh the the uh the news was covering
his speech uh he was in a town called
Laurel Maryland all right over in Prince
George's County and he was in the
parking lot giving a speech there were
some black guys in the back of the crowd
and a bunch of white people up front and
he was giving his you know racist speech
and um all of a sudden boom boom boom
right on live TV he got shot everybody
turned and looked at the black people
it was a white guy up front named Arthur
bremmer who shot uh George Wallace okay
Arthur Brimley just got out of prison a
couple years ago anyway he went to
Hagerstown prison
um
later George Wallace spent the rest of
his life in a wheelchair as a result of
that shooting
from the wheelchair
he said he was wrong he changed his his
racist attitude now most people don't
remember that they remember him
segregation today tomorrow forever you
know they remember the negative stuff
but they don't remember that Wallace
changed his tune
so I will just say
I I uh
I think it's it's funny you mentioned
everyone looked at the black people it
was a white guy because you know why
don't you they assumed the people who
are mad at him were probably black
exactly but the funny thing is today
when it comes to issues of critical race
Theory it is white is white people who
are advocating this mostly and that may
be a a of the fact that white people of
the majority of this country so you'll
see more white people advocating for
critical race Theory but typically a lot
of these Progressive ideologies like
gender ideology or race ideology come
from White liberals it's also you say
more white people advocating for
critical race Theory it's also more of
white people advocating to ban critical
race Theory yeah I think one of the
issues is that people are confused and
they're not arguing the same thing
exactly that's my whole point there's so
many different definitions of it right
you have yours Crenshaw has hers candy
has his what's that lady's name Robin
somebody she has hers I think critical
race Praxis should be banned the same as
Christian Christian practice should be
banned we shouldn't be putting ideology
in our curriculum but we can teach about
what the ideology is so the issue is
like if a Florida school said
Jesus died and on the third day he rose
again if a day has 24 hours how many
hours was it until Jesus rose again I'd
be like yo that should not be in a math
book right is it would you would you
think that's appropriate for a public
school math math problem
um well you gotta understand something
when I grew up and was going to school
first thing we did in class was stand up
and pray
and say and say the Pledge of Allegiance
you would pray as well yeah yeah we all
said a prayer but but based on today's
standards in which we don't allow prayer
in public schools oh I mean do you think
prayer should be in public schools I
think so oh okay however
I think people
um if it depends about the classroom
okay if if there's an Islam uh a Muslim
person in the classroom and there's a
Jewish person and there's a Christian
person or Hindu person I think they each
should say a prayer someone if someone
is an atheist then they can they can opt
to leave the room or remain seated or do
whatever they want to do because they
should be respected as well have no
Chris H just said Congress officially
apologized for slavery in 2008 no they
didn't no
you want to look it up somebody yeah
what was the statement Congress
officially apologized for slavery in
2008 were they legit let's find out
first official uh technology I think
we've gone way long I know you got to go
and we gotta rap so I'm gonna read just
we'll just read one more
uh we'll read two more actually the
first one will come from uh Maltese as a
black man I disagree with quite a bit of
what Daryl said but I will forever
respect this man's action better than
any antifa Thug has done
and then there is there's another really
good one that we need to read because
it's the most important one where did it
go oh there we go Andrew Lance says
thank you Daryl this has been a really
good conversation that reminds me of
many I have had with various black
friends I've known
I think people uh I just gotta say for
everybody who watches or listens to the
show
we are trying to have more discussions
over ideas that we disagree with we're
trying to make more of that we're I I
that we routinely invite people on the
left or Progressive or whatever they
just don't want to come on the show some
are and we have a few books and um it's
good to have these conversations so well
you know I want to say this as well you
know I I appreciate everybody who who
has put in their chat whether I agree
with them or not whether I call them a
racist or not I appreciate their
expressing their viewpoints okay and I
think we should have more of these
discussions so I hope we can do that now
to your point about these people who are
on the left or whatever who don't want
to come
um I was invited
a couple years ago
to this this lady called me up she's a
sociologist professor
and um she wanted to know what I
consider
coming to a uh a a dinner Gathering
uh with some people on the left and some
people on the right
and she named um a few uh White
supremacists uh one being Richard
Spencer
and um I said sure
so uh you know they they didn't reveal
where the dinner was to be held until
the day of
and uh because they wanted to keep it
secret or whatever
so on the day of I got I got the email
as to what address to come to et cetera
et cetera at what time and I showed up
and there were all these people over
there on the right Richard Spencer some
other Neo-Nazi type people and this and
the other and we had dinner together
no one from the left but me showed up
and you know they they backed out at the
last minute that's exactly what happens
yeah well you know I'm not one of those
who back out I will I will stand up to
anybody and everybody and you're welcome
to agree with me you're welcome to
disagree with me but let's have the
conversation I agree man you know and I
appreciate you having me on the show I
appreciate you coming man I thought this
was fantastic uh we you know if people
don't get along or if people disagree or
even if they agree I think we most I
think we agree on a lot more than we
disagree and I think we just highlighted
this agreements because we disagree we
want to express those the most you know
I think often the conversations we have
in agreement it's like well yeah of
course we agree on those things but then
let's move on to the things we don't
know right exactly let's get hot so
considering we've gone way too late
tonight oh I want to point out you were
right uh Congress apologizes for slavery
there's a lot of NPR stuff from 2008
apparently the U.S House of
Representatives issued an unprecedented
apology to Black Americans for the
institution of slavery and the
subsequent Jim Crow laws for years of
discrimination uh Steve Cohen Democrat
from Tennessee drafted the resolution
now to be be honest my personal opinion
platitudes you want real a real apology
is fixing the system but thank you for
at least putting forth an official
apology Congress at some point I don't
know here's what we got to do so
everyone is actually saying you know who
do we have to bribe to have you have a
conversation with Thomas Sowell
which would be oh that'd be amazing so I
don't know if that's if we can of course
we can all right Thomas so
uh John McWhorter oh yeah a lot of other
people you know they have their opinions
some I agree with some I don't agree
with it doesn't make them right doesn't
make me wrong it doesn't make me right
and them wrong or whatever I I think
people would just love to see the
intellectual uh clash as it were like
the the ideas presented yeah I know
people maybe we'll do that this summer
in June people get a kick out of seeing
black people fight each other for
whatever reason white people get a kick
out of that okay I I I'm telling you all
get the movie go on uh it used to be on
Netflix it's not on there anymore Amazon
Prime or iTunes okay it's called
accidental courtesy
and they followed me around the country
when I was interviewing KKK and
neo-nazis Etc and they they set me up to
interview some people uh a faction of a
black lives matter
and there was a major clash between me
and black lives matter it happened at
our event and um yeah but but you're
gonna see this on film and you're gonna
see about eight minutes
this went on for about an hour and it
almost erupted into violence wow okay
take a look at that you know they they
did not respect you know what I stood
for what I did et cetera et cetera now a
year later
they reached out to me and said you know
we've been seeing you we've been reading
some interviews you know we we sort of
get what you're doing you know you know
we want to try to work together you know
we don't agree with everything but we
think you know we can find some you know
Common Ground so we met and we had
dinner and we started working together
and then one of them fell off the wagon
and reverted back to himself in you know
in the film but
you will you will see uh you know in in
the whole movie the whole movie
uh
everybody talks about that particular
scene because for whatever reason now
you're gonna call me a racist again and
that's fine if you want to call me that
a lot of white people try to put black
people in one box we are not monolithic
we are as individual as white people
okay
um
just like you know people say well you
know you're you're black leaders you
know should do this and do that who are
my black leaders you know
is it Sharpton is it Jesse Jackson is it
Obama is it Thomas soul is it John
McWhorter I mean who are my black
leaders who who are your white leaders
is it Donald Trump is it is the Imperial
wizard of the Obama plan I'm My Own it's
Obama it's well well exactly you know
you have you have all your own
[Music]
well we don't we don't have white
leaders we had an orange leader for a
little while right yeah yeah technically
well he thinks he's still with it now
let's get specific about skin tone color
he thinks he's still well you know what
the best thing that I saw
you know I I I'm still doing this I
still go to Clan rallies and and all
kinds of all that kind of stuff but one
of the best things I saw I went to a
clan rally
and it was it was held on the lawn of
the governor's mansion all right and um
in in the state capitol and um they're
all these protesters and all the state
police keeping the protesters at a
distance from the the people in the
robes and hoods well these people showed
up who had painted themselves green
and they were yelling green power green
power that was the best thing I'd ever
seen yeah because I'm kind of pink your
skin tone is a little Auburn now I like
the specifics now we're nuanced we are
we are we went way late for a Friday but
it was really good Daryl this was
fantastic thank you so much for coming
back not everybody not everybody uh
liked the show but right 88 liked the
show and um I I think people should
expect two things we are going to have
conversations with uh over District like
we'll disagree on people will not agree
and I am not a master debater I am not a
debater but you know we'll have
conversations and so if the issue is you
feel like I don't do a good enough job
well maybe we should actually do like
what we did with Charlie kirken and vosh
and we'll have people who actually have
you know want to have a debate have a
debate here but don't expect me I'm not
that kind of guy right so uh if you do
like the show and you appreciate that
we're doing our best I thank you so much
for watching and if you don't like it
thanks for watching anyway your top to
your opinions and we respect all of your
comments and everything head over to
timcast.com if you want to support the
show support our journalists you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast Daryl do you want
to shout anything out hey really
appreciate everybody you can find me at
Daryl davis.com
d-a-r-o-y-l one-r at davis.com right on
and thank you for attending hope and
come back sometime absolutely yeah we'll
do it yeah thanks for having me everyone
uh I'm Bill find me at mines.com all
right I'm Ian Crossland and I love you
guys thank you for coming everybody Tim
you're great man this is really cool and
uh one more time in your documentary the
name of it accidental courtesy
accidental courtesy look for it on
iTunes or Amazon Prime beautiful
and thank you guys very much for tuning
in it's been a very engaging
conversation a lot of fun I always love
sparring conversation like this and I'm
really glad that we went along this
evening it's always more interesting
it's way more interesting to have
someone you don't agree with fully on
any one thing anyway you guys can follow
me on Twitter and minds.com at Sarah
patchlands one last shout out Colin
Steven said Tim get Thomas Sowell and
Clarence Thomas on oh yeah sure yeah
that would be one of the greatest shows
ever for any podcast at any point ever
I would love that
well I'll throw some coins into a
wishing well and see if they can make it
happen thanks for hanging out everybody
and we'll see you all next time wait
wait wait is it too late okay go to
chicken City watch chicken sleeping uh
YouTube chickencitilive.com all right
we'll see you later bye